je constate c'est qu'on est le 36e pays
en matière de vaccination
bon ça prouve à quel point on a un
système efficace
en normandie on aura deux usines qui
bientôt produiront des vaccins qui pour
l'un va être bientôt autorisés sur le
marché compte tenu de la faiblesse de la
vaccination je vois pas comment dans
quatre à six semaines
on pourrait se retrouver libéré
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue pour deux
heures d'émission nous décrypterons
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités et nos reporters sur le terrain
tout de suite voici les grands titres de
l'actualité de ce mercredi 31 mars à
quelle sauce va t'on être mangés dans
quelques instants la prise de parole
attendu des manuels macron plusieurs
scénarios envisagés fermeture des écoles
pour un mois confirmant street
extension de la vaccination quelles
options le président va-t-il choisir
pour freiner la troisième vague
réponse dans quelques secondes le coc
vit d'ailleurs dans le monde l enquête
de l'om est sous le feu des critiques
notamment américaines en cause des
incohérences dans le rapport notamment
sur la question de la provenance du
virus les mots ou chauves souris enrichi
justement avec 50 locaux vides destinés
aux animaux efficace à 100% vient d'être
homologué devrait être produit en masse
17 avril à est tout de suite place au
direct on écoute emmanuel macron de
l'outre-mer et de l'étranger la crise
sanitaire que nous traversons cette
épidémie de covin 19 dure depuis
maintenant plus d'un an un an de peine
d'épreuves où nous aurons été au moins
quatre millions et demi a contracté la
maladie et où bientôt cent mille
familles auront été endeuillée un an
d'efforts pour tous d'angoise de
sacrifice de fierté aussi et d'actes
héroïques un an ou ensemble nous avons
résisté et a pris nous avons tenu
je vous l'avais dit dès le début nous
allions vivre avec le virus
et c'est bien cela alors si ce soir je
m'adresse à vous avec autant d'humilité
que de détermination
c'est pour vous dire que nous allons
tenir encore essayé de faire le point
sur l'épidémie
les prochaines étapes essayez de vous
dire que si nous restons unis solidaires
si nous savons durant les prochaines
semaines nous organiser alors nous
verrons le bout du tunnel et nous nous
retrouverons
si je m'adresse à vous ce soir c'est
pour appeler à la mobilisation de chacun
pour ce mois d'avril où beaucoup se joue
où en sommes-nous aujourd'hui après un
confinement dur lors de la première
vague au printemps 2020 puis ce qu'on a
appelé un confinement adapté lors de la
seconde vague à l'automne dernier nous
avons opté depuis le début de cette
année 2021 pour une réponse qui visaient
à freiner l'épidémie sans nous confiner
trois principes n'ont cessé de nous
guider
d'abord la sécurité vous protégez ne
jamais transiger sur la santé des
françaises et des français
permettre à chacun d'être soignés dans
les meilleures conditions
ensuite le deuxième principe c'est l'
équilibre
c'est à dire prendre en compte les
conséquences aussi des restrictions sur
nos enfants et leur éducation sur
l'économie la société la santé mentale
notamment des plus jeunes
veillez à ne pas pénaliser les
territoires où le virus circule - ou peu
et puis le troisième principe c'est la
responsabilité
c'est à dire faire confiance préférer
aux contraintes pour tous le civisme de
chacun pour avoir les bons comportements
face au virus
limiter ses contacts se faire tester aux
premiers symptômes et s'isoler lorsqu'on
est positif sécurité équilibre
responsabilité
ce sont ces trois principes qui nous ont
conduits fin janvier à privilégier le
renforcement de cette stratégie tester
alerte et protéger le couvre-feu la
fermeture de certains établissements sur
leur confinement général du pays
nous avons tous consenti des efforts
importants et le virus a continué de
circuler il circule encore aujourd'hui
fortement
mais là où beaucoup de nos voisins ont
décidé de confirmer
il ya maintenant quatre mois nos voisins
allemands par exemple là où nos amis
italiens en sont à leur quatrième
confinement
nous avons aussi par ses choix
collectifs que nous avons fait gagner
des jours précieux de liberté les
semaines d'apprentissage pour nos
enfants
nous avons permis à des centaines de
milliers de travailleurs de garder la
tête hors de l'eau sans jamais perdre le
contrôle de l'épidémie
nous avons donc je le crois bien fait
croire en la responsabilité des français
ça n'est jamais un pari ces dernières
semaines nous faisons face à une
nouvelle donne depuis
au fond les premiers jours du mois nous
sommes entrés dans une course de vitesse
d'un côté le déploiement de la
vaccination qui permet d'espérer
raisonnablement une sortie de crise et
je vais y revenir et de l'autre la
propagation dans toute l'europe d'une
nouvelle forme de virus
ce variant qui a été identifiée pour la
première fois chez nos voisins
britanniques qu'à la fin de l'année
dernière et qui en quelque sorte a fait
apparaître une épidémie dans l'épidémie
celle ci est plus étendue qu'au
printemps dernier ce qui fait qu'aucune
région métropolitaine n'est désormais
épargner et celle ci est aussi plus
dangereuse qu'à l'automne ce qui fait
que le virus est plus contagieux mais
aussi plus meurtriers les services de
réanimation ont à prendre en charge des
personnes en bonne santé qui ont
aujourd'hui 60 ans même cinquante ans
quelques uns parfois plus jeunes
roth mais un chiffre 44 % des patients
en réanimation ont aujourd'hui moins de
65 ans face à ce double phénomène
nous avons décidé le 18 mars de prendre
pour près de 20 départements des
restrictions complémentaire au
couvre-feu national qui était déjà en
vigueur
deux semaines après la mise en place de
ces mesures les chiffres sont clairs oui
cette stratégie a eu des premiers effets
mais très clairement ces efforts restent
trop limité au moment où l'épidémie
accélère en quelque sorte
nous sommes en train de subir cette
accélération à cause du variant qui
risque
nous faire perdre contrôle si nous ne
bougeons pas nous devons donc nous fixer
pour les mois à venir un nouveau cadre
pour cela il ne faut absolument pas
céder à la panique
nous avons conservé la maîtrise de la
situation à l'hôpital
cette situation est dure beaucoup de
services sont surchargés mais nous n'en
avons pas perdu le contrôle nous ne
devons pas non plus céder au déni ce
serait faux de dire que si nous ne
faisions rien les choses
s'amélioreraient d'elle-même non alors
nous nous placerions dans une situation
délicate de potentiel saturation de tout
le pays aussi pour continuer à protéger
la vie au présent c'est à dire les
malades et pour protéger la vie au futur
c'est à dire nos enfants nous devons
pour les mois à venir
fournir chacun un effort supplémentaire
c'est cela ce que je nous demandent
collectivement ce soir un effort des
soignants d'abord pour augmenter nos
capacités en réanimation
je veux ce soir salué à nouveau en votre
nom à tous l'action remarquable de nos
soignants et en particulier des équipes
de réanimation et de soins critiques qui
secteur public comme secteur privé
agissent main dans la main mutualisent
les équipes innove
non seulement pour soigner les 28
malades du code vide à l'hôpital mais
aussi pour transformer des salles
d'opération en salle de réanimation pour
assurer une continuité de soins pour les
patients atteints de maladies graves
comme le cancer pour tous les moyens
d'urgence faire en sorte que tous les
reçoivent
et que tous puissent avoir les soins
dont ils ont besoin
en mars dernier à cette heure ci nous
les applaudit sion
n'oublions pas que depuis un an ils sont
sur le pont sans relâche pour augmenter
encore le nombre de personnes pouvant
être accueillis en réanimation centraux
des programmes et ils sont et seront
appuyés dans les prochains jours par des
renforts supplémentaires le nombre de
lits en réanimation a déjà été porté à 7
milles et je veux ici remercié les
étudiants en médecine les retraités
le service de santé des armées tous les
volontaires de la réserve sanitaire
tous sont mobilisés seront mobilisés de
manière accrue pour porter dans les
prochains jours notre capacité à un peu
plus de dix mille lits en particulier
aussi avec l'ouverture de nouvelles
capacités d'accueil dans certains
hôpitaux parisiens deuxième effort qui
nous concerne tous celui ci les règles
qui sont en vigueur dans les dix neuf
départements en vigilance renforcée
ces règles seront étendues à tout le
territoire métropolitain
dès ce samedi soir et pour quatre
semaines
si nous faisons ce choix qui ne concerne
pas une territoires d'outre-mer ce
territoire où le virus circule moins et
territoires qui d'ailleurs pour certains
ont fait de très gros efforts il ya
plusieurs semaines pour ralentir aussi
le virus de leur côté
si nous faisons ce choix douché tout le
territoire métropolitain
c'est parce que plus aucune région
métropolitaine mais aujourd'hui épargné
partout le virus circule vite de plus en
plus vite et par tous les
hospitalisations augmente et donc chacun
doit veiller non pas à s'enfermer
mais à limiter au maximum les contacts
les rencontres les moments de proximité
avec d'autres personnes très
concrètement ça veut dire que le
couvre-feu à 19 heures sera maintenue
par tous
le télétravail qui est sans doute la
mesure la plus efficace
le télétravail sera systématisé et
j'appelle tous les travailleurs et tous
les employeurs à y avoir recours à
chaque fois qu'ils le peuvent
les commerces seront fermés tous les
territoires métropolitains
selon l'âge liste déjà défini dans les
dix-neuf départements aujourd'hui
concernés nos citoyens qui souhaitent
changer de région pour aller s'isoler
pourront le faire durant ce week-end de
pâques les françaises et les français de
l'étranger qui veulent rentrer en france
pourront aussi le faire à tout moment et
nous ferons tout
pour faciliter les trajets et le
quotidien de nos concitoyens
travailleurs transfrontaliers
alors certains militent et je le sais
pour le retour généralisé de
l'attestation comme en mars 2020 nous
n'avons pas retenu cette option parce
que l'irresponsabilité de quelques uns
ne doit pas ruiner les efforts de tous
les contrôles les sanctions seront
renforcés sur la voie publique pour
limiter les régler rassemblement parce
que c'est là que le danger existe et
pour encadrer la consommation d'alcool
mais très clairement nous faisons le
choix de la confiance
nous faisons le choix de la
responsabilité et si je puis dire de la
respiration
l'attestation ne sera donc obligatoire
en journée que pour les déplacements au
delà de 10 km du domicile en cette
période qui est marquée par de
nombreuses fêtes religieuses
je sais aussi pouvoir compter sur vous
afin d'éviter comme nous avons su le
faire à noël les rassemblements privé
les fêtes avec les amis la famille les
proches
j'insiste vraiment sur ce point 7
lors de ces occasions que nous nous
contamine ont le plus il faut donc faire
cet effort fait un effort pour vous
protéger et pour protéger les autres
s'agissant des écoles et c'est quelque
sorte le troisième effort que nous
allons faire dans les semaines qui
viennent
s'agissant des écoles nous devons tous
être conscients de nos devoirs vis-à-vis
de notre jeunesse nous pouvons nous
féliciter dans notre pays d'avoir
réouvert parmi les premiers nos écoles
au printemps dernier le 11 mais
rappelez-vous et de les avoir maintenus
ouverte depuis septembre 2020
faisons partie des rares pays qui ont
fait ce choix alors même que nous avons
été très frappé par l'épidémie
nous l'avons fait en conscience parce
que nous croyons dans cet investissement
dans les jeunes enfants les adolescents
qu'est l'éducation parce que c'est le
combat du siècle qui s'ouvre car nos
enfants ont besoin d'apprendre d'être
ensemble et nul ne sait dire les
conséquences profondes et durables d'une
fermeture prolongée des écoles qui
renforce les inégalités sociales comme
les inégalités de destin alors oui le
virus circule dans les établissements
scolaires mais pas plus qu'ailleurs et
l'éducation de nos enfants elle n'est
pas négociable l'école n'est pas
négociable
c'est pourquoi nous devons prendre nos
responsabilités oui il faut freiner le
virus aussi nous allons fermer durant
trois semaines les crèches les écoles
les collèges et les lycées
mais oui nous devons préserver
l'éducation et l'apprentissage
c'est pour cela que le calendrier
scolaire sera adapté pour ne pas laisser
nos enfants
seul et sans apprendre de manière très
concrète cela signifie que la semaine
prochaine
les cours pour les écoles collèges et
lycées se feront à la maison sauf comme
au printemps 2020 pour les enfants des
soignants et de quelques autres
professions qui seront accueillis de
même que les enfants en situation de
handicap qui doivent continuer à pouvoir
être accueillis dans le secteur médico
social
les deux semaines suivantes soit à
partir du 12 avril
la france entière quelle que soit la
zone de vacances sera placée en vacances
de printemps
la rentrée aura donc lieu pour tous le
26 avril
physiquement pour les maternelles et les
primaires à distance pour les collèges
les lycées le 3 mai les collégiens et
les lycéens pourront retrouver
physiquement leur établissement le cas
échéant avec des jauges adapté je sais
croyez moi ce que cette réorganisation
implique de changement profond pour les
parents d'élèves et pour les familles
mais c'est la solution la plus adaptée
pour freiner le virus tout en préservant
l'éducation et donc l'avenir de nos
enfants
les étudiants quant à eux pourront pour
ceux qui le souhaitent continuer durant
toute cette période à se rendre à
l'université pour une journée de cours
par semaine
je veux ce soir en votre nom
remercier et saluer tous nos enseignants
et avec tous nos enseignants d'ailleurs
l'ensemble des personnels qui permettent
d'accueillir nos enfants dans les écoles
les collèges les lycées dans les
établissements spécialisés aussi car si
la france est un des pays à avoir le
moins fermer ses écoles comme je vous le
disais 42 semaines d'ouverture parfois
deux ou trois fois plus que certains de
nos voisins
c'est grâce à ave enfin comme depuis un
an
l'accompagnement économique et social
sera au rendez vous les parents qui
devront garder leur enfant et ne peuvent
pas t'aider travail et auront droit au
chômage partiel et pour les salariés les
commerçants les indépendants les
entrepreneurs et les entreprises tous
les dispositifs actuellement en vigueur
seront prolongées
je sais combien les efforts que je vous
demande sont difficiles je mesure ce
qu'ils emportent de conséquences pour
notre pays et pour vos vies et vous
savez aussi que nous avons tout fait
pour prendre ses décisions le plus tard
possible
et au moment où elle devenait
strictement nécessaire c'est maintenant
mais je tiens en même temps à vous dire
ce soir que grâce à la vaccination
la sortie de crise se dessine enfin
parce que oui à cette heure vous êtes
déjà plus de huit millions et demi à
avoir reçu une première injection de
vaccin 3 millions à en avoir reçu 2 et
le vaccin est efficace il est au bout de
quinze jours après l'injection de la
deuxième dose la meilleure preuve
d'ailleurs de cette efficacité est dans
les chiffres
vous voyez à cet instant à votre écran
et dans la mortalité en particulier de
nos concitoyens de plus de 80 ans qui
ont la mortalité qui a très fortement
diminué
la meilleure preuve elle en est
d'ailleurs dans la situation des
résidents des maisons de retraite qui
vacciner à plus de 90% ont pu
progressivement reprendre une vie
normale
notre enjeu principal aujourd'hui c'est
donc d'accélérer encore et encore cette
mobilisation c'est celle évidemment du
gouvernement de nous tous et de tous les
soignants là encore avec une stratégie
claire d'abord continuer à avoir de plus
en plus de doses en accélérant nos
achats et surtout en produisant en
france et en europe
nous sommes pleinement mobilisés il ya
eu des retards
il y a eu des choses que nous avons
corrigé
je pourrais revenir mais dans les
semaines à venir nous allons encore
accélérer le nombre de doses que nous
obtenons et nous allons progressivement
devenir le premier continent au monde en
termes de production de vaccins c'est
construire notre indépendance c'est
garantir que s'il faut des doses
supplémentaires
nous ne dépendrons plus des autres c'est
garantir aussi la production de nouveaux
vaccins
s'il y avait à nouveau à l'automne hiver
ou l'année prochaine des nouvelles
vaccination à prévoir ensuite c'est
vacciner le plus vite possible tous ceux
qui en ont le plus besoin c'est à dire
les plus âgés les plus fragiles ceux qui
ont le plus de risques de développer des
formes graves et j'assume totalement
cette priorité cet ordre que nous avons
donnée parce que c'est la garantie de
notre efficacité
c'est ainsi que nous pourrons soulager
plus rapidement l'hôpital
c'est ainsi que nous sauveront des vies
à partir de là nous mettons tous les
moyens pour vacciner vacciner vacciner
sans répit cent jours fériés le samedi
et le dimanche comme la semaine pour les
vaccins pfizer et moderna qui nécessite
des conditions de conservation
spécifiques
il y à 1700 centres de vaccination qui
ont ouvert notamment grâce à
l'engagement exemplaire de nos mères que
je veux ici remercier une fois encore
pour les vins ce pour les vaccins
astrazeneca et demain johnson & johnson
tous les médecins généralistes
pharmaciens infirmiers et infirmières
sont mobilisés au total 250 mille
professionnels médecins pharmaciens
sapeurs pompiers infirmiers vétérinaires
sont aujourd'hui prêts à contribuer à ce
grand effort national
si vous avez plus de 55 ans et être
atteint par exemple de diabète
d'hypertension ou de surpoids
vous pouvez aujourd'hui prendre rendez
vous auprès de votre médecin votre
infirmer votre pharmacien qui vous
vaccinera directement avec le vaccin
astrazeneca
cela a commencé depuis la semaine
dernière et nous allons accélérer à
mesure que les doses seront livrés les
1700 centres ouverts sont à disposition
pour eux vacciner avec les vaccins à
pfizer et moderna est aujourd'hui
vacciner donc tous nos concitoyens qui
ont plus de 70 ans
les vaccinant les vaccinations sont en
cours et elles accélèrent partout
je sais que beaucoup de nos aînés ont
essayé de prendre rendez vous pour se
faire vacciner ces dernières semaines
trop souvent son succès et j'en suis
profondément désolé ce n'est pas
acceptable
c'est pourquoi j'ai demandé à
l'assurance maladie de mobiliser des
équipes pour y remédier depuis quelques
jours si vous avez plus de 75 ans vous
avez peut-être déjà reçu des appels car
l'ensemble des plus de 75 ans qui n'ont
pas réussi à obtenir un rendez-vous
seront appelés par nos services
pour pouvoir le lire fixé et en
parallèle un numéro spécial sera mis à
disposition pour prendre un rendez-vous
à partir du 16 avril
les premiers rendez vous seront accordés
aux personnes qui ont entre 60 et 70 ans
à partir du 15 mai les premiers
rendez-vous seront ouverts pour nos
concitoyens qui ont entre 50 et 60 ans
et à partir de la mi juin
les rendez-vous seront ouverts à
l'ensemble des françaises et des
français de moins de 50 ans une
stratégie de vaccination spécifique sera
par ailleurs prévu pour toutes les
professions les plus exposés en
particulier nos enseignants
que j'évoquais tout à l'heure mais aussi
nos forces de l'ordre et plusieurs
autres nous tiendrons l'objectif que je
nous ai fixé à savoir que d'ici à la fin
de l'été tous les français de plus de 18
ans qui le souhaitent pourront être
vaccinés
parce que c'est la clé pour renouer avec
la vie la clé pour ouvrir notre pays mes
chers compatriotes les efforts d'avril
d'une part et le déploiement de la
vaccination d'autre part c'est cette
taille qui va nous permettre de contenir
progressivement ce nouveau virus
cette taille qui va nous permettre à
partir de la mi mai deux commencé à
rouvrir progressivement le pays a
retrouvé cette culture qui nous a tant
manqué à retrouver les lieux de
rencontre les commerces à retrouver cet
art de vivre à la française que sont les
restaurants les cafés que nous aimons
tant je reviendrai vers vous
prochainement pour préciser un agenda de
réouverture et pour que chacun puisse
aussi se projeter avec plus de
visibilité dans les mois qui viennent
dès la mi mai nous recommencerons à
ouvrir avec des règles strictes certains
lieux de culture nous autoriserons sous
conditions l'ouverture de terrasses et
nous allons bâtir entre la mi mai et le
début de l'été un calendrier de
réouverture progressive pour la culture
le sport les loisirs l'événementiel nos
cafés et restaurants mais d'ici là je
sais pouvoir compter sur vous mes chers
compatriotes je sais qu'il ya beaucoup
de lassitude de fatigue
je sais qu'il ya aussi parfois de
l'énervement de l'emportement et c'est
bien normal
je sais qu'à chaque étape de cette
épidémie
nous pourrions nous dire que nous
aurions pu faire mieux que nous avons
commis des erreurs tout cela est vrai
mais je sais une chose nous avons tenu
nous avons appris et nous nous sommes à
chaque fois améliorée alors oui
aujourd'hui pour le mois qui vient
il nous faut nous mobiliser nous
mobiliser pour nos aînés et les plus
fragiles et nous mobiliser pour nos
enfants pour les protéger et leur
permettre de continuer à apprendre et
leur préparer le pays et le continent le
monde auquel ils ont droit
nous mobiliser parce que le succès de ce
mois d'avril et de cette stratégie
dépend de chacun d'entre nous de notre
esprit de responsabilité
c'est ainsi que nous pourrons rebâtir ce
chemin d'espoir celui qui nous permettra
de retrouver progressivement une vie
normale celui qui nous permettra aussi
de tirer ensemble toutes les leçons de
cette épreuve mais nous tiendrons unis
et déterminés
vive la république et vive la france
et voilà vous venait d'écouter cette
allocution d' emmanuel macron 24 heures
des locutions avec plusieurs annonces
qu'on va décrypter ensemble avec nos
invités tout de suite
trois invités c'est donc le décryptage
et nous sommes avec benjamin marc
professeur d'histoire et porte parole
cgt 94 bonsoir benjamin arnau benedetti
rédacteur en chef de la revue politique
et parlementaire maxime thibeault
docteur en droit bonsoir messieurs merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
alors on va essayer d'être clair si on
peut l'être parce que c'est vrai que
c'est toujours un petit peu compliqué je
ne sais pas si de votre côté c'est d'une
clarté
voilà limpide mais c'est vrai qu'il faut
essayer de décrypter ce discours avec
des vacances des zones qui se mélangent
voilà bonne chance pour pour les parents
benjamin a marre vous l'enseignant vous
qui avez eu d'ailleurs le coc vide on se
souvient qu'ils étaient très en pointant
sur les fermetures d'écoles pendant de
nombreux mois
votre réaction déjà concernant ce qui va
modifier la vie de nombreux français et
de nombreux parents cette fermeture des
écoles cette modification du calendrier
scolaire c'est ce que vous attendiez sur
cette question sur cet aspect là très
précisément
rappelons que ce que nous demandions
depuis maintenant un certain temps
depuis la rentrée c'était que si on
partait du constat des manuels matheron
que nous sommes en guerre contre le coc
vie de 10,9 alors si on est en guerre on
met les moyens et nous on était d'accord
avec l'idée qu'il fallait à tout prix
éviter la fermeture des écoles mais dans
ces cas là il fallait se donner les
moyens
je rappelle que les 2000 groupe dans les
lycées on les a gagnés à l'huile de
coude après une semaine de mobilisation
à monsieur lancker cède au bout de cinq
jours de mobilisation d'ailleurs je vais
vous dire un truc dans mon lycée on a eu
des retraits sur salaire pour
votre équipe n'a exercé voilà c'est vous
dire alors que les deux groupes sont
toujours actée et donc il a fallu se
bagarrer dont on ne cesse de demander
depuis la réquisition de bâtiments des
recrutements extraordinaire de personnel
et de cette manière là on aurait pu à la
fois faire baisser la circulation du
virus est en même temps assurer un
encadrement pédagogique de qualité en
prenant en compte effectivement les
règles sanitaires mais rien n'a été fait
ce sont toujours les mêmes règles
libérales et donc qu'est-ce qui se passe
eh bien le mantra du gouvernement
c'était on ne ferme pas les écoles voilà
comme comment dire une moule accroché à
son rocher il répétait sa 116 et bien au
bout d'un moment fatalement ce sur quoi
ils avaient parié fondé toute leur
stratégie s'effondrer on ferme les
écoles mais parce qu'encore une fois et
c'est d'ailleurs le sens que je donne
moi cette intervention
finalement c'est le même disque rayé que
l'année dernière quand monsieur macron
avait ce ton mélodramatique en 2020 bon
très bien mais là c'est le même pathos
alors que la pandémie est là depuis un
an
donc c'est le constat d'un échec d'abord
dans l'éducation je viens de vous dire
pourquoi mais également sur les autres
secteurs
arnaud benedetti on va essayer voilà de
prendre un peu de hauteur et d'y voir
plus clair sur cette tonalité de
discours déjà vous le communicant macron
qui essayent minium les cons qui
essayent davantage de responsabilités
rézé les français avec un confinement
qui s'étend à tout le territoire mais
pas de confinement strict votre réaction
globale ce soit de la variation sur un
même thème en l'occurrence la politique
court après le virus et la communication
coup après la politique en l'occurrence
c'est ce qui caractérise finalement je
crois cette intervention de ce soir on a
eu d'abord toute une séquence avec des
pré-annonces qui finalement ont été
certifiés et confirmée par le président
de la république avec cette allocution
devant les françaises et les français
donc il n'y a pas véritablement un effet
de nouveauté parce qu'à partir du moment
où l'elysée avait fait le show en termes
de communication de laisser fuiter ce
cas les dires le président de la
république on s'attendait pour
l'essentiel à ce qu'ils allaient à le
penser
donc il n'y a strictement aucun l'effet
de surprise dans la communication de
l'exécutif
ensuite manifestement moment il ya une
formule qui m'a vraiment frappé en fin
d'intervention il a parlé de la teneur
il a dit on va prendre obtenant il
épidémie entre une stratégie qui
consiste à accélérer la vaccination et à
freiner l'épidémie par un niveau de
relèvement des contraintes mais en fait
son inconscient a parlé dans la manière
d'une certaine façon
la réalité c'est que aujourd'hui c'est
sa stratégie qu'il est en tenaille et
c'est comme ça que une grande partie de
l'opinion perçoit ce qui est en train de
se passer depuis quelques semaines c'est
à dire qu'il a fait un choix le 29
janvier qui était un choix contre l'avis
de son conseil scientifique c'est à dire
de re confiné alors c'est un choix qui
peut être pouvait s'entendre moi je n'ai
aucune compétence d'épidémiologistes en
la matière mais manifestement les faits
ont démontré que cette fois ci les
modèles épidémiologiques qui a été
présenté au président de la république
au mois de janvier se sont confirmées
pour le mois de mars
donc on a toujours un sentiment de
malaise avec cette communication parce
que c'est une communication qui donne
l'impression d'abord de vouloir
absolument protéger et justifier les
options qui ont été celles de l'exécutif
ensuite on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui
clairement on est dans une situation où
le président continue à essayer de
trouver une marge de la leur entre les
nécessités économiques et les nécessités
salutaire je ne suis pas sûr que la
multiplication des annonces qu'il a pu
faire aujourd'hui dans cet exercice soit
en tout cas immédiatement audible et
nécessitera vrai sens moment un
décryptage dans les heures qui viennent
mexico vous le docteur en droit comment
vous percevez ce soir c'est énonce des
manuels macron parce que c'est vrai qu'à
chaque fois ça semble être un roulement
de tambour on attend voilà je vais être
un petit peu taquine mais que le roi de
france nous disent qu'on a le droit de
faire de ne pas faire votre réaction ce
soir on avait eu les ballons d'essai
c'est à dire qu'il avait déjà commencé
de confiner sans vouloir utiliser terme
parce que pour lui le confinement c'est
le symbole de son échec à tout prix il
ne voulait pas confiné il avait déjà
commencé de remettre des restrictions
dans certaines régions et ce soir et les
uns généralise
on le savait on savait d'avancé qu'en
fait ils tendaient vers une
acceptabilité des mesures parce que
l'objectif des manuels macro et c'est
comme ça qu'il gouverne depuis le début
il n'est pas là pour représenter la vo
lu la volonté populaire il n'est pas là
pour avoir l'accord des français
lorsqu'il prend une décision il est là
pour entraîner l'acceptation de ces
derniers des mesures qu'il va décider
dont il avait commencé de le faire avec
le confinement à paris du moins les
mesures qu'on a connu à paris l'affairé
avec lyon il l'a fait avec pas mal de
départements il en fait ils appelaient
pratiquement à toutes les métropoles
françaises et il est venu finalement à
l'étendre sur l'ensemble du territoire
national donc on ne voit aucune
différence
moi ce qui me dérange fondamentalement
c'est que on a la preuve est en tout cas
eux n'ont pas la preuve que les mesures
de restriction sont efficaces pour
lutter efficacement contre le coc vide
aux cantons commencent à faire la
comparaison internationale
on voit que des états comme la suède des
états comme l'espagne et des états
fédérés des états unis d'amérique n'ont
pas eu des mesures aussi forte en terme
de restrictions sanitaires et pour
autant n'ont pas eu une évolution de
l'épidémie
au point d'avoir les quatre cent mille
morts que nous annonçait manuel macron
bas de décembre
et ça ça me dérange parce qu'en réalité
on a encore vu ce soir une
concrétisation d'un principe qui à mon
sens et illibérale c'est le principe de
précaution l'objectif d' emmanuel macron
c'est de prévenir tout problème d'un
point de vue de sa responsabilité
politique et de la point de vue de la
responsabilité pénale de ses ministres
en ayant des mesures qui sont parfois
plus contraignant que nécessaire et vous
avez une étude l'étude vigile qui a été
rendu il semblait hier qui a démontré
que dans les écoles la maladie n'a pas
évolué le taux en fait d'incidence
évolué parce qu'on fait beaucoup plus de
tests mais le nombre de tests positifs
reste le même c'est à dire à peu près 3
4% et on a eu toute une communication
emmanuel macron pour nous faire peur
pour nous faire peur nous faire peur que
nos enfants tombent malades et que
derrière il donne la maladie à nos
parents à nos grands parents pour
conduire finalement la fermeture de
l'école c'est c'est je trouve terrible
parce forme et toujours sur le même
triptyque qui est assez simple l'émotion
par la peur
l'infantilisation et là il ya juste un
point positif c'est il a supprimé
l'attestation dans le périmètre de 10 km
heureusement que c'était le symbole de
cette infantilisation et le troisième
c'est la culpabilisation et ça c'est
assez c'est assez trainer je suis pas un
expert en communication et arnaud
benedettini le reprendra certainement
mais vous avez toujours des messages
positifs qui sont ponctuées de la part
d' emmanuel macron par des sortes de
compliments ou de deux petites remarques
en disant vous avez fait des efforts ou
bien vous n'en avez pas assez fait ou
bien vous penserez en faire davantage
pour faire culpabiliser les français
comme si en réalité l'épidémie était de
leur faute
alors qu'en réalité elle est de la faute
de ce gouvernement qui n'a pas suggéré
la politique vaccinale et il n'a pas eu
une politique concrète depuis un an
en tout cas maxime thibeault satao
culpabilité le gouvernement ne semble
pas se l'appliquer pas de mea culpa de
la part du chef de l'état que l'on
écoute là où beaucoup de nos voisins ont
décidé de confiner il y a maintenant
quatre mois
nos voisins allemands par exemple là où
nos amis italiens en sont à leur
quatrième confinement nous avons aussi
par ses choix collectifs que nous avons
fait gagner des jours précieux de
liberté des semaines d'apprentissage
pour nos enfants
nous avons permis à des centaines de
milliers de travailleurs de garder la
tête hors de l'eau sans jamais perdre le
contrôle de l'épidémie
nous avons donc je le crois bien fait
croire en la responsabilité des français
ça n'est jamais un pari ça c'est vrai
que c'est récurrent à ceux qui suivent
les traditionnelle conférence de presse
de jeudi il ya rarement un mea culpa
nous avons bien fait nous dit emmanuel
macron ce soir benjamin a marre votre
réaction
quant à cette non remise en cause de
la part du gouvernement mais cros et du
chef de l'état lui-même à côté c'est pas
dit mot quand j'ai préparé l'émission va
le j'écoutais assidûment ce qu'avait dit
le président j'avais une feuille à côté
cette phrase les écrite elle est
hallucinante
elle est hallucinant parce qu'en fait on
touche là je pense à la fois quelque
chose qui relève de la psychologie
individuelle des manuels macron mais qui
a pour le coup ruisselé dans toute sa
majorité
c'est à dire que ces gens au niveau de
la morgue et de l'arrogance je pense
qu'ils ont leur douzième dan à ce niveau
là c'est de la virtuosité
on a une situation sanitaire
hallucinante on vient d'évoquer quel
point emmanuel macron avait été
finalement en contradiction avec le
conseil scientifique et à tort mais il
nous explique qu'il a tous mieux fait et
mieux fait partout ailleurs c'est
sidérant les bras m'en tombent
mais moi j'aimerais réagir aussi sur
autre chose au départ il a le toupet en
yiddish on dit la route pas de parler de
solidarité
doit-on rappeler ou alors est ce que
nous avons tous des problèmes de mémoire
tampon qu emmanuel macron à imposer au
mois de janvier une réforme de l'aide au
logement qui va se solder par 700
millions d'euros des dents - pour les
allocataires et qu'il met en place au
forceps une réforme de l'unedic
unanimement condamnée par les
partenaires sociaux
voilà et après ce monsieur a le culot de
venir nous parler de la solidarité
alors qu'on a 1 millions de pauvres
supplémentaires voilà la messe est dite
voilà pourquoi je vous disais tout à
l'heure le même jukebox rayé et avec
effectivement toujours la même petite
musique du satisfecit et de l'auto
satisfaction
voilà césar jupiter se décerne à
lui-même des lauriers mais un moment ou
un autre
fatalement il y aura un retour de
boomerang parce que pour les français
je ne sais pas comment l'opinion va
ressentir cela en tout cas moi je trouve
ça insupportable
on va poser des questions communicants
arnaud benedetti comment l'opinion
justement va recevoir tout ça c'est vrai
que on a du mal on digère tout senti
peler les mesures ceux qui ont des
enfants sont en train de faire leurs
calculs mon dieu qu'est ce qu'on va en
faire parce que dans deux jours il va
falloir qu'il reste la maison si j'ai
bien compris en ses enfants c'est pas
aisée pour tout le monde
votre avis justement pour cette
acceptabilité de l'opinion publique
comment vous la santé
c'est très bien de résilience jusqu'à
maintenant mais il ya quand même une
autre continue qui a accompagné la
gestion de cette crise sanitaire et des
études d'opinion qui ont été effectués
depuis le début de cette gestion ont
démontré c'est que il y à une méfiance
et une absence de confiance dans la
façon dont l'exécutif gère cette crise
depuis le début depuis le mois de mars
de l'année dernière donc cette tonalité
à mon sens après le discours du
président de la république ce soir ne
devrait pas fondamentalement évolué et
moi je suis quand même très surpris par
la multiplicité des annonces ou des
demies annonces qui sont faites on a
l'impression d'un président de la
république est au milieu du gué qu'il
veut jamais faire le pas supplémentaire
dans une direction dont une autre comme
s'il gérait au doigt mouillé cette
épidémie et c'est ce qui ressort quand
même des discussions d'ailleurs qu'on
peut avoir avec les françaises et des
français lorsqu'on lorsqu'on lorsqu'on
les interroge c'est à dire qu' il ne
voit pas véritablement la stratégie
globale qui guident l'exécutif dans la
gestion de cette épidémie par contre ce
qu'il semble c'est que la question des
moyens à la question de l'organisation
la question de la logistique qui est la
question matricielle des des
dysfonctionnements dans cette crise
depuis le début persiste c'est à dire
qu'en fait le décor général n'a pas
fondamentalement changé par rapport à
celui de mars 2020 et ce sentiment de
surplace alors évidemment le président
de la république a essayé de combattre
en fin d'allocution on annonce ont de
manière à mon sens très audacieuse
calendrier de réouverture pour le début
du mois de mai afin de donner un peu de
perspective est un peu d'espoir aux
françaises et aux français et est ce que
ce sera suffisant pour les convaincre on
peut avoir aujourd'hui des doutes
contenu quand même delà de la façon dont
le le le pays réagit par rapport à la
gestion de cette de cette épidémie
effectivement je vais pas demander plus
qu'un pas de médecin sur ce plateau
l'efficacité de ces mesures mais on peut
peut-être je ne sais pas en douter
concrètement ça veut dire quoi que
pendant trois semaines d'école c'est ça
le gros des annonces ce soir c'est le
confinement nationale mais finalement
enfin on a on a du mal finalement à voir
les effets de ces nouvelles annonces
maxime thébaux 7000 id réa qui passe à
dix mille y est ce que c'est bien
suffisant aujourd'hui alors qu'il me
semble qu'à nice on a des lits de
réanimation qui sont en train de fermer
et que depuis trente ans on a une
politique en terre sur le service public
hospitalier et a été désastreuse et qui
a été celle de passer d'un hôpital de
stock
c'est à dire qui prévoit des nids vers
un hôpital de flux qui n'a plus la
capacité de répondre aux crises mais qui
répond au tout venant des malades
je note qu'une chose et ça il faut il
faut bien soulever à chaque fois que
vous avez un contentieux devant le
conseil d'état
et dernièrement vous avez le cercle
droits et libertés qui a saisi le
conseil d'état en référé liberté contre
le couvre-feu est bien le gouvernement
n'a pas pu apporter la preuve que ces
mesures étaient efficaces pour lutter
contre le co lead aucune preuve et même
le conseil d'état les cris le conseil
d'état dit il le semble que ces mesures
aient permis finalement de lutter contre
le colis mais il n'y a aucune preuve
et ça c'est vraiment problématique c'est
à dire que je reviens au principe de
précaution ce principe de précaution y
conduit derrière à des privations de
liberté qui sont terribles et a des
conséquences de ces mesures de
restriction qui le sont aussi
on a vu le nombre de suicides augmentent
et on a vu le nombre de dépressions chez
les enfants chez les étudiants on a vu
le nombre de faim de maladie
psychologique a explosé on a vu les
problèmes dans l'éducation nos enfants
notamment les plus petits par le fait
qu'il subissait les mesures de
restriction et ce qui me gêne beaucoup
c'est que le gouvernement ne fasse pas
preuve de précaution vis-à-vis des
autres aspects de la vie et reste dans
vague d'un raisonnement pardon pied
purement sectoriel c'est à dire que
emmanuel macron à l' influence de
médecins qui sont en plus des pompiers
pyromanes
les médecins de plateaux télé qu'on va
toute la journée sont parmi les
responsables de la politique
hospitalière qu'on a connu depuis trente
ans donc c'est quand même
particulièrement désastreux mais
il donne la parole il laisse parler ses
personnes qui ont un raisonnement
purement sectorielle qui me regardent
que des courbes et qui ont finalement
oublié ce qui est le serment
d'hippocrate et qui est celui de voir la
vie dans sa globalité et il les écoute
en oubliant que la viny entière est en
train finalement d'être progressivement
abandonné et progressivement les
français tombent dans un état
psychologique qui est de pire en pire et
moi c'est le vrai problème et je
regrette emmanuel macron même temps
revienne pas là-dessus en tout cas est
la seule solution pour lui est
d'ailleurs pour tout le monde ça semble
être la vaccination benjamin lamarche
voulez vous interpellez justement on
parlait de cette piste la vaccination
avancée pour les enseignants ça ne
semble pas être le cas ils devront
patienter en tout cas ça sera en
fonction de l'âge
c'est une déception dans les écoles
j'imagine pour les enseignants que vous
êtes
c'est un sujet de plaisanteries acides
dans la salle des profs en tout cas dans
mon établissement puisque s'ils
voulaient encore une fois on a
régulièrement ces exercices de prise de
parole gouvernemental ou présidentielle
où on nous annonce des trucs en
s'imaginant que l'on n'oublie banon on
se souvient qu'en janvier
monsieur blanc caire nous proposait une
une vaccination en retour de la mi mars
puis ensuite effectivement ça s'est
reportée sur la mi avril
et puis ça va être les calendes grecques
mais je vais vous donner un autre
exemple si vous me le permettez plus
plus personnel emmanuel macron à dire
quand vous avez des problèmes de diabète
ou d'hypertension artérielle et bien
vous allez chez votre médecin il pourra
effectivement vous vacciner à
astrazeneca toi moi j'écris père tension
c'est d'ailleurs ce qui m'a valu la
forme grave du coc vite 19 qui
d'ailleurs a fait exploser ma tension
artérielle il faut le savoir eh bien
quand j'ai vu mon médecin il ya de cela
dix jours je lui ai dit mais alors
comment ça se passe il me dit bah
écoutez j'ai ouvert une attestation avec
votre hypertension artérielle
on va voir essayer de jouer le coup dans
les centres de vaccination peut être à
partir de la mi-mai essayer de voir si
vous allez si vous allez arriver à vous
faire vacciner surtout pas l'astra et
les gars parce que quand on est jeune
comme vous ça peut créer des thromboses
donc voilà entre
la messe présidentielle et la réalité du
terrain que ce soit dans la salle des
profs dans le cabinet du médecin voyez
il ya une galaxie et ça aussi ça nourrit
bien évidemment le mécontentement la
colère et une certaine forme de
lassitude extrême
merci en tout cas à tous les trois je
rappelle en ce calendrier de vaccination
31 mars les plus de 70 ans 16 avril les
plus de 60 ans et le 15 mai donc les
plus de lait - pardon les plus de 50 ans
excusez moi on seront hyper merci à tous
les trois messieurs val chammam a un os
benedetti et maxime thiébaut merci
d'avoir été avec nous pour commenter
donc ces annonces des manuels macron le
rapport de l'organisation mondiale de la
santé sur l'origine du coc vide au coeur
d'une polémique beaucoup d'incohérences
ont pointé dans le rapport notamment sa
provenance du laboratoire chinois une
hypothèse peu probable pour l'om est ce
un rapport que fustige les états unis
les précisions de walid bennani il avait
quitté rouane le 10 février souriant les
experts de l'om s et leurs homologues
chinois avaient rendu les premières
conclusions sur les origines du coc vie
19 presque deux mois plus tard le
rapport a été rendu public un rapport
qui suscite de nombreuses réactions les
interrogations sont toujours nombreuses
l'hypothèse d'une fuite du coronavirus
d'un laboratoire chinois y est notamment
décrite comme extrêmement improbable une
déclaration qui est loin de satisfaire
la demande mondiale sur l'origine de la
pandémie
nous sommes d'accord et nous disons
depuis longtemps comme je viens de le
dire qu'il manque des données des
informations cruciales
il n'y a pas eu d'accès cela manque de
transparence d'après notre évaluation à
ce jour qu'il soit à la hauteur de la
situation et de l'impact que cette
pandémie a eu sur la population mondiale
les états unis et 13 pays alliés comme
le royaume uni et israël ou encore le
japon on réclame aujourd'hui plus de
transparence et de coopération de la
part du gouvernement chinois
des investigations supplémentaires
doivent être poursuivis par des experts
indépendants souhait de l'union
européenne et du patron de l'om est oui
même de son côté pékin rejette toute
controverse et le terme
de complaisance la chine n'acceptera
jamais les accusations sans fondements
et les calomnies gratuite de la partie
américaine sur la question de l'épidémie
une douzaine d'experts mandatés en chine
du 14 janvier au 9 février dernier entre
quarantaine de 14 juin plusieurs visites
encadrées et médiatisés comme celle de
l'institut de virologie de one et d'un
marché local désigné comme le premier
foyer de l'épidémie
quinze mois après l'apparition des
premiers cas de kovy 19 l'hypothèse
d'une transmission du virus à l'homme
par l'intermédiaire d'un animal infecté
et qualifiés de probables à très
probable ces dernières heures le chef de
la mission en chine et experts de l'eau
m s a de son côté légitimer le travail
de ses confrères waka d'accès stockons
nous avons eu accès à un grand nombre de
données
mais bien sûr il y à des domaines où
nous avons eu des difficultés à obtenir
les données brutes en chine comme dans
de nombreux autres pays il existe des
restrictions et des lois sur la
protection de la vie privée en
particulier si les données sortent du
pays
personne ne s'attendait à ce que cette
mission apporte une réponse définitive
et que nous avions à la fin de la
mission avec un animal quelconque dans
les mains et que nous disions voici le
coupable
cela n'a jamais été l'intention ou la
tante expectations à noter que le
rapport n'écarte pas également
l'hypothèse d'une transmission par de la
viande surgelée
ainsi afin d'éviter de futurs
interrogations et une nouvelle crise
sanitaire
mardi le président du conseil européen
et le directeur de oms soutenu par le
président français et la chancelière
allemande ont appelé à élaborer un
traité international sur les pandémies
et nous sommes avec l'autre
blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales bonsoir claude à
branches maison mère
on dirait que sur rt france on l'entend
du nord est mais ce qui veut donc une
enquête éventuelle bonsoir fuite d'un
laboratoire en chine pourquoi ce
changement de ton tout d'un coup ah ben
tu es drôle vibrer février le directeur
général de l oms
revis retrouve des couleurs puisque il
ya un an il était accusé des pires maux
par le président trump qui considérait
pratiquement que le directeur de l' oms
était un agent chinois en effet monsieur
que voyez vous savez un peu tardé à
déclarer l'état d'urgence humanitaire et
sans doute sous la pression chinoise et
puis il y avait de mauvaises habitudes
prises à l' oms puisque avant avant
monsieur gebreyesus il ya eu pendant
plus de dix ans une directrice générale
chinoise
alors aujourd'hui ce trump est parti et
joe biden est revenu à l'om est ce que
les états unis avaient avait quitté est
évidemment le représentant des états
unis al om s expose la position
américaine et par conséquent fait
pression sur le directeur général pour
avoir des réponses aux questions posées
et c'est dans ces conditions que en
effet le directeur général de l'om est
dit que la mission qui revient apporte
des résultats qui laisse beaucoup de
questions dans l'ombre
beaucoup de questions n'ont pas de
réponse il faut donc renvoyé d'autres
missions qu'ils rechercheront sur place
les sources de ce virus cela dit les
autres missions probablement certes ce
retour au même problème c'est que sur
place ils sont bien obligés de
travailler avec leurs homologues chinois
et que leurs homologues chinois leur
montre ce qu'ils veulent bien leur
montrer
et puis nous sommes quand même plus d'un
an après le début de la pandémie a one
et probablement que locaux ont pu être
nettoyé que
les témoignages ont pu être filtrés et
que c'est très très difficile de mener
aujourd'hui une enquête indépendante à
one plonge maison vous restez avec nous
si vous voulez bien on va évoquer ce
vaccin anti covit désormais pour les
animaux questions majeures justement si
l'on considère qu'un intermédiaire
d'origine animale était entre le virus
et l'homme efficace à 100% ce vaccin
vient d'être homologué en russie le
sérum russe anti copie 19 carnival cove
est le premier produit destiné aux
animaux ces essais cliniques avait
débuté en octobre dernier il devait être
produit en masse 17 avril
il a été développé pour par une filiale
de rossel rozanoff le centre fédéral de
santé animale en contact avec à des
entreprises d'élevage d'animaux à
fourrure on écoute le chef adjoint du
laboratoire
ce vaccin a été élaboré l'année dernière
plutôt notre institut le centre fédéral
de santé animale avait effectué toute
une série de recherches scientifiques
à la veille de l'élaboration du vaccin
lui même nous avons développé des
méthodes de diagnostic en laboratoire et
des systèmes de dépistage pcr dans le
sang des animaux
tout d'abord ce vaccin est conçu pour
les animaux sensibles comme je les dis
ce sont des animaux à fourrure donc pour
les fermes de l'élevage de ces animaux
l'expérience internationale a montré
qu'il y avait des foyers infectieux chez
des animaux à fourrure l'année dernière
au danemark et aux pays bas ce qui a eu
des conséquences économiques assez
sérieuse et bien sûr le vaccin est
également conçu pour les animaux
domestiques
en ce qui concerne la vaccination en
masse des animaux domestiques pour
l'instant nous considérons que l'on n'a
pas besoin mais nous y sommes prêts
aujourd'hui le vaccin a été enregistré
et sa production industrielle sera
lancée toujours avec nous encore un
vaccin pour les russes celui pour les
animaux donc les rues sont ni
manifestement le paquet sur la recherche
contre le coc vite c'est important pour
un grand
monde de pays d'être en pointe de
l'innovation oui bien sûr les autorités
russes le gouvernement russes ont mis
comme vous le comme vous l'avez dit le
paquet et bien il y a un an et que tous
les laboratoires se sont mobilisés pour
rechercher les éléments de deux vaccins
anti quantico vide et on connaît la
valeur des scientifiques russes et
notamment dans ce domaine par conséquent
après le spoutnik v qui que dans
monsieur poutine a parlé pour la
première fois au début du mois d'août de
l'année dernière
eh bien aujourd'hui c'est un vaccin pour
les animaux qui donc est annoncée qui a
été homologué aujourd'hui même
d'ailleurs par les autorités compétentes
en russie alors ce n'est plus un sujet
pour l'organisation mondiale de la santé
est un sujet pour une autre organisation
internationale qui s'appelle
l'organisation internationale pour la
santé des animaux
c'est très important parce que les
épidémies chez les animaux peuvent avoir
une incidence d'abord sur l'alimentation
on l'a vu avec la grippe aviaire dans le
passé et puis sur la transmission
éventuellement à l'homme sur ce sujet
actuellement le ms dit qu'il n'ya pas de
preuves il puisse y avoir une
transmission directe à l'homme mais dans
le fond on n'en sait rien et donc ce
nouveau vaccin va être produit en russie
il a été testé et il semblait pour
efficace à 100%
d'après ce qui a été publié aujourd'hui
et naturellement il pourra être utilisé
sur les animaux domestiques les chats
les chiens et en effet il ya quelques
cas dans plusieurs pays y compris en
russie qui ont été déclarés et puis sur
les visons on vient de citer le danemark
et les pays bas où les élevages entier
devises ont dû être détruits parce que
il avait le cul 8,19 et d'autres animaux
comme
les renards notamment qui peuvent
contaminer qui peuvent contaminer
d'autres d'autres animaux eux-mêmes
alors justement tonnes d'anchois maison
dans ce contexte de pandémie la
discussion hier soir entre emmanuel
macron guélat merkel et vladimir poutine
alors du jour les vaccins notamment
pourquoi cette réunion était
indispensable pour asseoir les
différents je crois que c'est très
important parce que comme vous le savez
en fin de semaine il ya eu un conseil
européen en vidéoconférence au début de
ce conseil européen le président
monsieur charles michel a fait état
d'une conversation d'une heure et demie
qu'il venait d'avoir avec vladimir
poutine et au cours de cette
conversation delà des murs poutine avait
dit mais dans le fond il faut reprendre
langue avec l'union européenne
il faut que nous arrivions à trouver un
ordre du jour deux sujets positifs de
sujets sur lesquels on peut coopérer
ensemble et parmi ces sujets il a
évidemment inhumé ray le réchauffement
climatique bien sûr mais aussi la
coopération dans le domaine sanitaire
alors vous conseil européen
la question n'a pas été plus loin
puisque le le sujet a été renvoyé à une
session ultérieure
mais il est logique que la chancelière
allemande le président français et le
président russe reprenne ce point comme
d'autres d'ailleurs parce qu'il sait pas
le seul point qui sont évoqués dans
l'eure dans leurs conversations hier
mais c'est logique qu'ils reprennent ce
point et qu'ils évoquent en effet la
possibilité d'utiliser le vaccin scouts
nick v dès que l'autorité européenne des
médicaments
laurent homologué sans doute dans
quelques semaines
puisqu'une une mission doit se rendre en
russie pour examiner pour voir les
laboratoires qui fabriquent ce vaccin
est donc il ya encore un certain nombre
de deux examens à faire pour que ce
vaccin soit validée il pourra ensuite
être mis sur le marché il ya un certain
nombre de pays européens ont d'ores et
déjà indiqué qu'il utiliserait l'un même
l'a utilisée déjà
en utilisant son autorité purement
national de validation
c'est la hongrie mais je pense que
d'autres pays vont se déclarer
en tout cas tous les pays du sud de
l'europe l'ont déjà fait l'allemagne l'a
déjà fait et puis un certain nombre de
pays ont également déclaré qu'ils
étaient prêts à fabriquer ce produit
donc ils sont en négociation de nature
commerciale avec le fonds
d'investissement qui possède
l'entreprise qui fabrique ce vaccin en
russie pour pouvoir le fabriquer et pour
déterminer les conditions de cession du
brevet et dans quelles conditions ce
vaccin pourrait être fabriqué monsieur
mac on a beaucoup insisté encore ce soir
sur le fait qu' une entité comme l'union
européenne doit avoir une maîtrise
industrielle sur la fabrication que ces
vagues de ces vaccins eh bien je pense
que d'ici quelques mois le vaccin russe
sera aussi fabriqué à l'intérieur de
l'union européenne comme il l'est déjà
en 1 2 le contrat passé par le le fonds
le fonds qui possède l'entreprise de
vaccins et bien a passé un contrat avec
plusieurs laboratoires indiens avec
l'inde est le premier fabricant de
vaccins au monde et il a commandé 600
millions de vaccins 600 millions de
doses dont une grande partie est
destinée aux pays aux pays du
tiers-monde
merci claude manche maison expert en
relations internationales et dans
quelques instants nous reviendrons
évidemment sur ces annonces du président
mais kron puis nous parlerons également
des retraites puisque des manifestations
ont eu lieu partout en france
aujourd'hui pour réclamer une hausse des
pensions de retraite et de meilleure
prise en charge médicale
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez comme moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative on sort du pays il
est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
déçu l'univers l'uniforme c'est quand
même des hommes comment ces mecs-là
arrive à dormir la nuit là aussi je
pense qu'on a vécu quelque chose
d'inusité gilet jaune c'était des
valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
des gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas là j'oublie
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est en direct
il y a quand même la liberté je vous
remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
ce sont les trafics de drogue d'une
certaine façon qui sont peut-être les
meilleurs adeptes de la mondialisation
c'est à dire que ils ont inventé les
routes de la drogue bien avant que les
entreprises ne découvrent les bienfaits
de la mondialisation on ne visualise pas
à quel point ça peut être compliqué de
se retrouver avec dans son garage une
montagne de billets de banque comme ça
il faut en faire quelque chose de
l'argent sale devient très rapidement et
très facilement en gris et puis blanc il
suffit de passer par quelques sociétés
écrans
mais à côté de ça vous avez tout un
réseau de banques qui sont beaucoup plus
ouverte au cash à l'époque de la crise
de 2008 vous dit même que les banques
qui ont été beaucoup moins regardante
sur la provenance de cet argent qui
arrivaient pour renflouer les caisses ça
a été même dire nations unies on a
constaté que plusieurs dizaines de
milliards issus du trafic de stupéfiants
ont été absorbés par un certain nombre
de banques aux états unis qui d'ailleurs
ont été poursuivis en justice et ont
payé des amendes en conséquence
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous tes
coups politiques n'a jamais été obligé
de dire la vérité d idée courageuse des
mots qui compte on soit vient des
guignols
aujourd'hui on a une gauche extrêmement
tous les pots moins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview
[Musique]
21h merci nous rejoindre pour cette
deuxième un des missions tout fille doit
si les titres de l'actualité de ce
mercredi 31 mars les règles en vigueur
dans les 19 départements confiné étendue
à tout le territoire école fermée pour
trois semaines une tolérance pour se
déplacer entre région ce week-end ce
sont les principales annonces des
manuels macro ce soir le chef de l'état
qui espère toujours vacciner l'ensemble
de la population majeure d'ici la fin de
l'été
les retraités sont masqués mais pas
bâillonner environ 200 personnes se sont
rassemblées à paris aujourd'hui à
l'appel de neuf organisations syndicales
et associations de retraités
leur revendication de meilleures
pensions et plus de moyens pour leur
santé ils dénoncent la baisse de leur
pouvoir d'achat et la hausse de la
précarité à la demande de londres le
conseil de sécurité de l'onu qui se
réunit en urgence ce soir à new york au
sujet de la situation en birmanie une
réunion qui intervient alors que
washington a récemment donné de
nouvelles sanctions entre l'armée
birmane et le départ de ces diplomates
plus de 500 civils ont été tués depuis
le coup d'état du 1er février
[Musique]
laurent gbagbo à quitter la cour pénale
internationale confirme l'équipement de
crimes contre l'humanité de l'ex
président ivoirien ce dernier était
poursuivi avec son bras droit charles
blé goudé pour crimes contre l'humanité
en côte d'ivoire la procureure sortant
de la cpi fatou bensouda avait fait
appel
[Musique]
l'actualité dominée par les annonces des
manuels macron 24 minutes d'allocution à
20 heures pour en parler nous rejoignant
tout de suite notre reporter ben hassen
chébili bonsoir 20e
qu'est ce qu'on doit retenir des
annonces des manuels macron bassem
écoute et stéphanie c'était une
allocution qui était très attendue par
les français la question des massacres
ont pour éclaircir un petit peu sur les
nouvelles directives prises par le
gouvernement pour lutter contre cette
vague coronavirus il y avait plusieurs
scénarios dont celui d'un confinement
strict et dur comme celui qu'on a connu
sur l'année dernière l'exécutif a
tranché il n'y aura pas de confinement
street mais plutôt dès samedi prochain
les règles qui sont déjà appliqués aux
19 départements qui sont concernés par
les mesures le nouveau confinement
alléger ces règles là seront appliquées
à l'ensemble dû territoire métropolitain
le télétravail lui sera systématisé et
puis fortement conseillé les commerces
et resteront fermés selon une liste bien
détaillé nous pourrons nous déplacer ce
week end dans d'autres régions que c'est
ce qu'a annoncé le chef de l'état afin
de pouvoir aller se confiner dans une
autre région et puis bien sûr il y des
contrôles et des sanctions qui sur vous
renforcer sur l'ensemble du territoire
par les forces de l'ordre pour limiter
tous les rassemblements et il faudra
surtout se prémunir d'une attestation
pour pouvoir se déplacer au delà de 10
kilomètres d'ans
la l'ombre du jour y avait bien sûr la
question de l'école faut-il arrêter
l'école ne faut-il pas arrêter l'école
exécutif a tranché les écoles seront
fermées à partir de vendredi et ce pour
trois semaines sur l'ensemble du
territoire
écoutez maillot de macron nous allons
fermer durant trois semaines les crèches
les écoles les collèges et les lys de
manière très concrète cela signifie que
la semaine prochaine
les cours pour les écoles collèges et
lycées se feront à la maison les deux
semaines suivantes soit à partir du 12
avril
la france entière quelle que soit la
zone de vacances sera placée en vacances
de printemps
la rentrée aura donc lieu pour tous le
26 avril physiquement pour les
maternelles et les primaires à distance
pour les collèges et les lycées
le 3 mai les collégiens et les lycéens
pourront retrouver physiquement leur
établissement le cas échéant avec des
jauges adapté sem le président de la
république et a laissé entendre qu'on
pourrait revenir progressivement à une
vie la normale à compter de la mi mai
c'est stéphanie ce la fin de son
allocution que le chef de l'état a
insisté sur le devoir des français de
respecter ces règles et de lutter
ensemble contre le coronavirus avec des
règles qui restent inchangés comme le
couvre-feu à 19 heures ou bien sûr ce
confinement léger qui sera appliqué sur
l'ensemble du territoire mais surtout il
a insisté sur cette vaccination le chef
de l'état a dit qu'il fallait
massivement continuer à vacciner il n'y
aura pas de pause n'y aura pas de jours
fériés il de dimanche pour la
vaccination et c'est grâce à cette
vaccination qu'on pourra bien sûr
retrouver une vie normale il a cité les
trois vaccins qui sont disponibles en
france pour la vaccination à savoir
astrazeneca pfizer ou encore johnson &
johnson le chef de l'état a même insisté
sur le fait que d'ici la fin de l'été
tous les plus de 18 ans qui voudront se
faire vacciner pourront le faire sur la
base du volontariat et bien sûr à partir
de mi-mai nourrit ouvriront
progressivement les lieux de culture les
restaurants les bars bien sûr à
certaines conditions si le protocole est
respectée et si les résultats sont là
voilà stéphanie ce que l'on a pu heureux
d'obtenir de cette allocution du chef de
l'état sur les nouvelles mesures en
vigueur pour lutter contre cette
propagation du cornât virus merci bassem
chemière direct de l'assemblée tout de
suite nous retrouvons adexi poulain
notre éditorialiste bon soir à l'exo
merci d'être avec nous vous avez
évidemment suivi cette allocution alors
c'est vrai qu'on s'attendait où on
espérait peut-être soyons fous un
calendrier précis mais enfin il ya
beaucoup de confusion et surtout
beaucoup de chamboulement de dernière
minute notamment pour les vacances de
pâques de printemps qui concernent
énormément de français
oui beaucoup d'incertitudes
alors papa vraiment levé puisqu'on
attendait dont on ne savait pas s'il
parlait aujourd'hui ou sous quinze jours
il y avait beaucoup d'attentes de cette
allocution présidentielle qui finalement
redonne des dates de vacances scolaires
et et va fermer les écoles parce que oui
le virus circule dans les écoles
contrairement à ce qui avait été dit
pendant des mois par jean michel
blanquer et d'autres responsables
irresponsables donc là il est en train
de faire ce qu'il aurait dû faire
peut-être il ya quelques semaines son
pari est perdu c'était ce pari de
start-up heures de la voie étroite pour
ne par confiner nous voilà avec cette
étrange confinement maintenant sur tout
le territoire le couvre feu
19h les 10 km etc des règles
supplémentaires
l'interdiction de l'alcool dans les rues
également alors je ne sais pas quelle
corrélation sans doute parce que les
gens se retrouvent et puis que le
printemps arrive alors surtout pas
surtout pas de fêtes de liesse de joie
et de gens qui se retrouvent
l'idée c'était évidemment d'éviter ce
confinement là il n'a pas aidé éviter
pas plus que n'a été évité les semaines
de couvre feu à 18h les 30000 morts
également qu'ils sont à mettre au crédit
de cette stratégie
foot rare que des manuels macron qui
rappelez vous il y a quelques semaines
disait à des jeunes lors d'une sortie
dans le 93 qu'il fallait tenir encore
quatre à six semaines et bien maintenant
il nous dit qu'il faut tenir jusqu'à mi
mai donc clairement cet épidémiologiste
de talent ne sait pas ce qu'il fait même
si son entourage dit qu'il est
extraordinaire et il gère à la petite
semaine
une épidémie qui aujourd'hui le dépasse
il a annoncé encore l'ouverture en
urgence de dix mille lits de plus de
réanimation olivier ferrand avait
annoncé en août 2000 vingt douze mille
lits de réanimation qui pourrait être
ouvert rapidement en cas de crise ça n'a
pas été fait donc on voit bien que rien
n'a été fait on paye toujours les
cabinets de conseil tant que mc kinsey
et d'autre une fortune pour avoir des
slides on a vu ces images powerpoint
lors de l'allocution du président de la
république c'est nouveau avec les
chiffres les courbes pour expliquer que
nous allons repartir pour quelques
semaines de difficultés pour vaincre ce
virus avec évidemment l'idée c'est
d'attendre les doses de vaccin puisque
elles le sont toujours pas là et
l'europe ne produit toujours pas sur son
territoire suffisamment de vaccins pour
tous les pays alors pour autant alexis
pas vraiment de mea culpa il ya eu un
moment donné où on a esquissé voilà une
reconnaissance de quelques petites
erreurs mais vite corrigé en disant oui
mais on devient meilleur après mais dans
l'ensemble pas vraiment de mea culpa on
a bien fait a dit emmanuel macron oui on
a toujours bien fait et on est les
meilleurs il faut surtout pas comparer
avec les autres parce que de toute façon
la france c'est le meilleur pays avec le
meilleur président est la meilleure
stratégie
donc oui ça a été très court ce petit
moment d'émotion
où il a dit que oui peut-être qu'on
aurait pu faire les choses autrement
qu'il comprenait l'énervement la
lassitude des français que cela était
tout à fait normal mais que des erreurs
nous avons appris et nous sommes devenus
meilleurs je ne vois pas comment
pour moi cette allocution de mars 2021
nous ramène en mars 2020 on a fait du
surplace pendant un an puisque au lieu
de prévoir au lieu en décembre de mettre
en place déjà les protocoles pour que
les sapeurs pompiers les vétérinaires la
réserve des soignants s'organisent pour
la vaccination plutôt que d'aller
acheter des vaccins un peu partout comme
l'ont fait la grande bretagne et
d'autres pays mvele macron attendu
attendu attendu en essayant de voir si
éventuellement le variant anglais
éviterait comme le nuage de tchernobyl
les frontières du pays bas il n'en est
rien évidemment le variant anglais est
partout aujourd'hui et il est beaucoup
plus virulent c'est malheureux et c'est
ce qui fait qu'on doit revoir la
stratégie aujourd'hui alors c'est encore
une fois les plus faibles et les plus
pauvres qui vont trinquer puisque ce
week end vous pourrez aller si vous avez
une résidence secondaire et bien
rejoindre cette résidence secondaire les
cours à distance c'est il l'a rappelé
d'ailleurs c'est quelque chose de
difficile pour beaucoup d'enfants qui
n'ont pas accès à du matériel
informatique ou une connexion internet
donc tout ça va creuser encore les
inégalités tout ça va encore rendre plus
difficile une sortie de crise et la
repousser de quelques mois même si il a
commencé à donner quelques dates mi-mai
pour la réouverture de certaines
terrasses de certains lieux de culture
donc il ya quand même une lumière au
bout du tunnel mais on ne sait pas la
longueur du tunnel alors la longueur du
tunnel ça viendra avec les vaccins et là
aussi des annonces plutôt ambitieuse
tous les français d'ici la fin de l'été
bon pas de pas de surprise par avant
l'europe va devenir le plus grand
fournisseur de vaccins prochainement on
a hâte
mais là encore quand même beaucoup de
flou beaucoup de flou puisque quand il
parle par exemple des professions qui le
demande beaucoup d'efforts les soignants
ou bien les enseignants
là il n'y a pas de date ou de stratégie
sur la vaccination de ses métiers
qui sont en première ligne donc on ne
sait pas quelles vont être les vaccins
ni l'organisation de cette vaccination
rien non plus sur la recherche sur les
traitements puisqu'en parallèle des
vaccins si on parle de tonna il parlait
d'une taille contre le virus
il n'y a pas que les vaccins il ya aussi
des traitements précoces qui permettent
d'éviter que les formes graves arrive
trop tôt chez certains malades
d'ailleurs les soignants ont changé les
protocoles au moins eux ont appris au
moins eux ont avancé pendant sept années
perdues pour par l'exécutif et puis il y
a bien sûr l'idée de dire on va produire
suffisamment et les adultes de 18 ans et
plus pourront être tous vaccinés à
partir de la fin de l'été ceux qui le
désirent
avec évidemment l'instauration de ce
fameux passeport vaccinale le pass vert
à part l'union européenne tant vanté par
thierry breton qui lui parlait même
d'une sortie de crise pour le 14 juillet
mais rien n'a été dit par le président
de la république sur le report ou non
des élections régionales par exemple
donc on voit bien que toute cette
gestion est extrêmement sectorielles par
le petit bout de la lunette on ne voit
pas vraiment qu'est ce qu'il va se
passer c'est l'urgence qui prime c'est
répondre pour dire que ce président est
courageux qu'il est là pour agir contre
le virus et que son action est efficace
c'est uniquement ce à quoi sert cette
communication présidentielle puisque
réalité il n'y avait pas de raison de
faire une annonce comme celle ci olivier
parent ou jean castex aurait très bien
pu s'en charger tous les deux demain
jeudi soir comme ils ont l'habitude
chaque jeudi après le conseil de défense
d'égrainer les nouvelles mesures
mais là visiblement emmanuel macron
s'est dit que c'était le moment
peut-être de poser un jalon pour revenir
dans le jeu et dire qu'il était un
leader essentiel dans la gestion de
crise et en particulier de ce virus mnm
la con qui a aussi annoncé que les
dispositifs d aide aux entreprises et
aux salariés étaient maintenus mais il
n'en n'était pas vraiment étalé sur
cette question économie qui a déjà coûté
plusieurs dizaines
2 milliards à la france et on ne sait
toujours pas qui va payer 1 alors si
c'est nous qui allons payer nous les
contribuables tout simplement parce que
cet argent magique n'existe pas et c'est
surtout malheureusement le de nombreux
employés qui vont eux passés de chômage
partiel à chômage réel avec des plans de
licenciements qui vont sans doute
arriver des faillites qui sont
nombreuses des redressements
d'entreprise on parle d'une 15% environ
des entreprises zombies qui sont là mais
qui ne verront pas la fin du tunnel qui
déposeront le bilan à la fin de l'année
ou après tout ça évidemment va coûter
extrêmement cher
l'économie française aussi qui n'aura
peut-être pas le rebond escompté tant
attendu par eric le maire bruno le maire
pardon qui parlait d' de 6% de
croissance pour 2021
reste à voir ce qu'il en sera pour la
croissance française alors tous bien sûr
repose sur la stratégie vaccinale et la
réouverture des commerces une fois
encore ça fait plus d'un an que certains
commerces sont totalement fermés des
secteurs entiers qui sont sinistrés
le tourisme on ne sait pas ce qu'il en
sera pour cet été sans doute ce ne sera
pas une saison estivale comme les autres
donc évidemment pour de nombreux
professionnels chefs d'entreprise
l'horizon reste bouché compliqué hélas
le quoi qu'il en coûte aura un prix et
ce sera celui des feuilles celui du
chômage qui va exploser et celui de la
dette bien entendu cette fameuse dette
qu'ovide qui même si l'allemagne a bien
voulu octroyer quelques budgets
supplémentaires et de la dette
supplémentaire
ça ne durera qu'un temps il faudra
rembourser c'est ce que dit le directeur
de la banque de france et ce que disent
tous les économistes orthodoxes pour
assurer que la france remboursera bien
c'est d'être évident pour la rembourser
il faudra de la croissance davantage
travailler donc j'imagine que l'avenir
sera encore plus d'efforts après ces
efforts de court terme qu'on nous
demande pour lutter contre le virus
il faudra faire un effort collectif sans
doute avec la réforme des retraites la
réforme de l'assurance chômage mais
aussi les 35 heures le temps de travail
et bls bien d'autres choses pour
relancer l'économie française voilà ce
qui n'est pas dit que les non dits du
discours présidentiel qui risque
d'arriver bien après
il sans doute après 2022 justement les
retape merci alexis poulain d'avoir été
avec nous et justement l'excès bien d'en
parler c'est dans ce contexte que les
retraités ont manifesté cet après-midi
dans le monde nombreuses villes de
france à l'appel de neuf syndicats en
pleine crise sanitaire les
revendications sont multiples précarité
pouvoir d'achat défense des services
publics notamment de l'hôpital ou encore
difficultés d'accès à la vaccination
anti copie 19
les précisions de notre reporter david
kelly faire devant le ministère des
solidarités et de la santé un
rassemblement qui s'est terminée vers
15h30 ici devant le ministère de la
santé ils étaient entre 150 et 200 à
répondre à l'appel des unions
confédérales de retraités une action
placée sous le signe de la solidarité
intergénérationnelle à l'occasion de
dénoncer à des inégalités et qui se sont
accentuées avec la crise sanitaire née
qui existait déjà auparavant
les syndicalistes réclamaient une
revalorisation de leurs pensions jugées
beaucoup trop faible à titre d'exemple
de nombreux retraités vivent avec un peu
moins de 1000 euros par mois en france
qui accentue un peu plus le taux de
pauvreté pour ces catégories d'âge
il a atteint les 6 % pour les 60 elle
soixante dix ans et elle passe à 8 %
pour les plus de 75 ans adl syndicats
d'autres professions se sont également
rendus ici pour soutenir ce mouvement
mais également des politiques notamment
député de la france insoumise c'est le
cas de benoit test syndicats secrétaire
général du syndicat fsu et dans le rien
à quatre noms ce député la france
insoumise propose de les écouter
tout ce qu'on doit porter aujourd'hui en
termes de protection des retraités des
personnes âgées en termes de pouvoir
d'achat parce que ce sont des personnes
et des citoyennes et des citoyens qui
ont le droit de vivre de vivre décemment
avec de l'argent qu'ils n'ont pas volé
avec au contraire des droits qu'ils ont
acquis pendant leur leur travail tout ça
il faut continuer à le marteler à le
dire y compris par des mobilisations
parce que on est inquiet des
possibilités que ont continué à dégrader
le pouvoir d'achat des retraités
beaucoup réclament 300 euros
d'augmentation des pensions de retraite
c'est une juste revendication
et puis après au delà il ya la question
notamment aussi de l'accès au vaccin qui
se pose parce que parmi les retraités
beaucoup souhaiteraient pouvoir se faire
vacciner pouvoir avoir accès aux vaccins
et compte tenu de la politique d'
emmanuel macron complètement hasardeuse
de la gestion calamiteuse de la
stratégie vaccinale beaucoup de celles
et ceux qui aimeraient à 7h pouvoir se
faire vacciner ne le peuvent pas parce
que nous n'avons pas assez de vaccins
l'objectif des organisations syndicales
présentes à ici c'était également de
dénoncer le manque criant des
établissements de santé en france et a
réclamé une création d'emplois pour les
hôpitaux pour les ehpad et les services
d aide à domicile afin d'éviter une
nouvelle hécatombe
créé par le co by 19 notamment l'année
dernière
rassemblement statique donc à paris
mobilisation également à lyon et
marseille plusieurs centaines de
retraités ont défilé depuis ce matin de
la porte d'aix en direction de l'agencé
régionale de la santé ars jugée
incompétente dans sa gestion de la crise
selon les manifestants
réaction de certains d'entre eux au
micro d'isabelle ferrières les années 70
80 80 90 ça allait les retraites était
bienne ça leur plaît pas à ceux du
gouvernement
alors ils nous passent les retraites il
va nous qu'on revienne à la pauvreté est
d'ailleurs une grande partie des
retraités sont pauvres
je sais pas ce qui va nous arriver après
si on ne réussit pas notre combat pour
éviter que
que cette perdition des retraite bien
méritée des travailleurs des péniches
on nous accuse de sacrifier la jeunesse
d'arrêter l'économie au nous
discriminons nous infantilise on nous
culpabilise et nous disons que ça suffit
puisque si vous voulez tout ça c'est
pour masquer justement ceux qui
tenteraient de se passer c'est à dire le
manque de tout et pour en parler nous
sommes avec henri sterdyniak économiste
monde des économistes atterrés bonsoir
en mystères dignac merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur arte france les
retraités ont ils raison d'être
mécontents ce sont les sacrifiés du
gouvernement macro à les entendre les
retraités ont des raisons d'être inquiet
savait que la dette augmente aidé
physiquement et on a eu un rapport à
tuer qui prévoit de réduire à l'avenir
les dépenses publiques et en particulier
les dépenses sociales en particulier
donc les retraites des retraités ont des
raisons de s'inquiéter en plus les
retraites depuis quelques années ne
suivent pas l'inflation donc il ya eu
des baisses de pouvoir d'achat des
retraités il ya un certain nombre de
discours de bruno le maire sur lequel on
va retarder l'âge de départ à la
retraite ce qui peut inquiéter les ce
qu'il est les activistes sont proches de
l'âge de la retraite il ya dégradation
des services publics il a aussi très
particulièrement les retraités donc les
retraités ya actuellement il faut le
dire ne sont pas les personnels et la
catégorie les plus pauvres de la
population ont quand même des raisons de
s'inquiéter
clairement les retraites sont elles
menacées par le souci du gouvernement de
baisser les dépenses sociales pour
réduire le déficit public après 2022
déficit public qui risque on imagine de
s'aggraver fort oui bien sûr vous savez
que la france est l'un des pays qui
consacre
le plus retraite et vous savez eu à
bercy nos brion inspecteur des finances
considère que c'est sur les retraites
que il faut faire un effort
si on peut dire est que les retraites
sont beaucoup trop élevés en france et
donc il ya la tentation à chaque fois ne
pas indexer les retraites
et il ya la tentation d'augmenter les
les ponctions sur les retraités donc les
retraités ont raison de se mobiliser
pour combattre c'est cette tendance du
gouvernement
alors certains parlent de reculer l'âge
de départ alors que nous sommes en
chômage massif et ça risque encore
malheureusement de s'aggraver à en
croire les annonces a en tout cas on ne
se sent pas de cette pandémie cela vous
semble être une bonne idée
c'est une idée de bruno le maire c'est
une idée de sa fille et bertrand s'était
limité d'edouard philippe ça peut avoir
un sens à la limite si effectivement été
en situation de plein emploi
actuellement
ce serait vraiment une très mauvaise
idée là si on retarde d'un an l'âge de
départ à la retraite sur quatre cinq
cent mille personnes supplémentaires qui
restent dans les entreprises ou qui
cherchent un emploi
actuellement la priorité ça doit être de
d'inciter les entreprises à embaucher
des jeunes et non pas à conserver des
personnes âgées des personnes de plus de
60 62 ans
donc c'est tout à fait contre productif
aujourd'hui de d'évoquer cela si une
politique est nécessaire ça sera une
politique disant aux entreprises
vous devez absolument embaucher des
jeunes des apprentis des des jeunes en
contrat à durée indéterminée en contre
et si vous ne faites pas vous serez
sanctionné ce
c'est ce dont on a besoin actuellement
henri sterdyniak clairement vous pensez
que le gouvernement met kron va
poursuivre dans sa détermination de
réformer les retraites on a vu un des
membres du gouvernement bruno le maire
il ya quelques mois en pleine pandémie
dire qu'en gros on l'a ignoré cette
réforme mais ça risque de clairement
endommagé le climat social qui est déjà
très tendu la réforme envisagée par
macro était une réforme extrêmement
compliqué ils se heurtent au problème
des différentes professions
on a fait le problème des de tous les
enseignants qui étaient particulièrement
frappés par la réforme en a fait le
problème de reald régime autonome qui
était jaloux de leur autonomie dans tout
ça fait que ça demande des négociations
compliquées branche par branche
profession par profession
de toute évidence on n'a pas le temps de
faire c'est pas là qu'occupation donc la
réforme systémique prônée par macro on
peut dire elle est oubliée
pour ce quinquennat tout est là
ressortira aux prochaines élections
présidentielles
la seule chose que souhaite
éventuellement bruno le maire se serait
de prendre des mesures au de recul
rapide de large 2 du départ à la
retraite ce qui n'est pas possible
compte tenu de la situation du marché du
travail ne reste qu'une solution un peu
minable c'est là sous indexation des
repères de retraités du pouvoir d'achat
grâce à l'inflation mais ça va pas très
loin avec actuel membre
l'inflation n'est pas n'est pas très
forte et donc qu' on peut dire que le
dossier est obligatoirement gelé pour
l'année à venir
merci envie de serdinya que
économiquement des économistes atterrés
merci d'avoir été avec nous dans
quelques instants reste avec nous nous
parlerons de la birmanie
une situation ne cesse de se détériorer
avec plus de 500 morts depuis le début
des manifestations contre le coup d'état
militaire en février dernier le conseil
de sécurité de l'onu s'est réuni en
urgence aujourd'hui puis nous parlerons
de laurent gbagbo qui a été
définitivement acquitté par la cour
pénale internationale des accusations de
crimes de guerre qui pesait contre lui
[Musique]
vous êtes né dans la musique vous êtes
né dans une famille d'artistes désir
révélée brutalement par la prise de
conscience du concert symphonique qui
m'a donné envie d'être chef d'orchestre
ça a balayé tout le reste c'est un acte
d'amour la musique pour vous oui mais
l'art en général vous savez ça permet de
mieux se connaître ça permet de mieux
partager c'est la part d'humanité
incontournable et indispensable à
l'évolution de tout être humain quand
vous entendez pata pata pata pata pata
pata pata pata pata pata pas par an
pathamathan vous avez envie de faire ça
mais il faut que leur qu'istres groove
la musique c'est la traduction la plus
poétique de la vie si vous mettez pas la
vie des évidemment on s'embête il faut
sortir les notes de leurs univers
carcéral
mais il faut jouer ce qui entre les
notes et avant tout c'est le rythme et
la pulsation et ça c'est fondamental
pour entraîner l enthousiasme des
musiciens et celui du public
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
louis saillant est un ex commandos
marine il nous emmène dans les coulisses
de la guerre contre le djihadisme au
sahel l'ennemi l'abord est parfaitement
légitime qu'on parle de jay liste on
parle de gens qui recrutent des enfants
on parle de gens qui sont d'une barbarie
extrême c'est vrai que c'est un terreau
qui peut favoriser l'extension du
terrorisme ne faut pas imaginer qu'il
suffit simplement d'avoir un pays pauvre
pour que l'islam c'est un big mac sont
embrigadés ils ont été séduits ils ont
été manipulés et d'autres qui agissent
de manière parfaitement consciente et
lucide je respecterai toujours mon
adversaire même si je méprise totalement
son idéologie comme c'est le cas pour
sega liste
[Musique]
brigitte et pour tout ce que ça rapporte
aux enfants c'est une confiance
confiance en soi ils ont soif
d'apprendre et izm la connaissance mais
quelque chose les blocs aussi dans
l'apprentissage à l'école les enfants de
l'ambition ils veulent à accéder à des
gros poste veulent s'évader du quartier
qu'est ce qui ne fonctionne pas dans
l'apprentissage à l'école les
professeurs les écoles fonds nécessaires
mais je rencontre des instituteurs des
institutrices en ce1 ce2 il ya des
enfants qui ont vraiment encore du mal à
lire et à écrire
et c'est pénalisant pour l'enfant pour
leurs familles on oublie les parents qui
sont responsables du foyer est temps que
les parents ne maîtrise et ne parlent
pas le français à la maison basse avec
difficile
[Musique]
et y'a pas une façon plus une pauvre de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'elle nous trouve la
peuplent c'était une volonté collectés
vous le savez comme moi qui dès qu'on
dit il n'ya pas intervenir on sort du
pays
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre
il est probable qu'il faille prendre un
certain nombre de mesures un peu
autoritaire c'est intéressant on
comprend que vous soyez déçu l'univers
l'uniforme c'est quand même des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inusité gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent ces
gens qui avaient envie de transmettre
quelque chose à leurs enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas d'oubli
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est en direct
il y a quand même la liberté je vous
remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
21h30 souhaité bienvenue en direct sur
rt france si vous nous rejoignez réunion
en urgence ce soir à new york des 15
membres du conseil de sécurité des
nations unies à la demande du royaume
uni au menu de ce rendez-vous la
birmanie où les et les manifestations
perdure un mois et demi après le coup
d'état plus de 500 civils ont été tués
depuis le 1er février
si washington a ordonné de nouvelles
sanctions contre l'armée le départ de
ces diplomates moscou et pékin
dung quât fièrement leur opposition à la
violence de la junte refuse pour le
moment d'appliquer toute sanction à
l'égard du pouvoir en place
antoine ogi la menace d'une guerre
civile
plein de chaque jour un peu plus sur la
birmanie les factions ethniques elle
aussi prise pour cible par l'armée lors
de frappes aériennes se déclarent
désormais prête à se joindre au peuple
pour lutter contre l'oppression
militaire si les forces de sécurité
continuent à tuer des civils
nous collaborerons avec les manifestants
et nous riposterons par les armes
ce week-end l'union nationale karen
l'une des plus grosses factions armées
du pays a été prise pour cible par les
raids aériens après s'être emparé d'une
base militaire tuant dix soldats pendant
que les militaires tenait samedi matin
des célébrations de la journée des
forces armées dans la capitale signe de
la gravité de la situation
c'est la première fois depuis 1995 que
les militaires birmans s'en prennent à 7
est tenu des dizaines de blessés inclut
enfin des enfants ont depuis traversé la
frontière pour se réfugier en thaïlande
où des médecins les ont pris en charge
ce week-end plus de 3000 personnes ont
tenté de fuir le pays pour se réfugier
en thaïlande
mais dans un souci de protection des
frontières
le premier ministre thaïlandais a fait
intervenir l'armée pour les en empêcher
sans toutefois avoir recours à la
violence explique-t-il
nous avons discuté avec ceux qui sont
entrés en thaïlande
nous leur avons demandé s'il avait des
problèmes dans leur région et quand ils
ont dit qu'il n'y avait pas de problème
nous leur avons simplement demandé de
retourner d'abord sur leurs terres nous
leur avons demandés nous n'avons pas
utiliser la force si la communauté
internationale est d'accord pour
dénoncer les agissements de l'armée
birmane
une divergence oppose toujours certains
pays concernant l'adoption de sanctions
contrairement aux états unis et au
royaume uni la russie et la chine bien
qu'affirmant leur opposition à la
violence de la junte refuse pour le
moment d'appliquer toute sanction à
l'égard du pouvoir en place
la réunion du conseil de sécurité de ce
mercredi a pour objectif avec la
communauté internationale de trouver un
terrain d'entente pour venir en aide au
peuple birman depuis le coup d'état du
1er février dernier qui a fait tomber la
cheffe du gouvernement civil
aung san suu kyi plus de 500 personnes
ont péri sous les balles des forces
armées l'association d'assistance aux
prisonniers politiques une ong
thaïlandaise estiment que ce bilan est
sans doute bien plus élevé mais pour en
parler nous sommes avec alain patel
président de l'association médicale
franco asiatique bonsoir alain patel mer
si d'être avec nous conseil de sécurité
donc de l'onu en urgence à new york pour
le moment aucune information n'a filtré
à quoi doit-on s'attendre aux soit
l'issue de cette réunion
je crois que la chine et la russie
auront leur veto il y aura sûrement de
bonnes résolutions mais je crois qu'il
ya deux choses ce soir qui sont très
importantes sait déjà que le
gouvernement en exil le cerf ph qui est
le seul gouvernement normalement élu a
promulgué la nouvelle constitution du
pays et celle ci il y à quelques heures
c'est un événement formidable car il
avait parfaitement prévu que le 1er
avril il y aura une nouvelle
constitution qui abolirait la
constitution de 2008 qui donnait un tas
de pouvoir aux militaires
alors les sanctions c'est très bien on
va en parler certainement il faut
étrangler financièrement les militaires
les américains on priait des mesures
dont pas seulement sur les généraux en
bloquant leur prendre bancaire mais sur
les conglomérats les deux grands
conglomérats dont tous les généraux
colonels et rotonde et actions et qui
leur permettent d'avoir des revenus
importants c'est pour ça qu'ils veulent
se maintient au pouvoir
nous on a pas être très fiers en france
parce qu' un certain nombre de
compagnies étrangères ont dit qu'elles
se retiraient de la birmanie des
japonais des coréens est par contre même
nous nous ne devons pas être fier car
accor le groupe accor hôtelier a dit
qu'il restait en birmanie c'est à dire
il continue à supporter la junte et ce
qui est plus important c'est le groupe
pétrolier total qui exportent tout le
gage vers la thaïlande et qui verse 250
millions de dollars par an de taxes à la
junte a dit qu'il ne quitterait pas le
pays
ceci n'est pas la gloire des entreprises
françaises
alors vous avez évoqué ces sanctions
notamment prononcé par les etats-unis et
le royaume-uni envers les militaires
mais en ce sens ils n'ont pas vraiment
d'effet ces sanctions comment faire
pression sur eux
ben là je ne vous ai pas cité mais il ya
quand même la firme allemande qui femmes
qui donnent tout le papier pour
fabriquer les billets de banque a
immédiatement dit qu'il ne livrer plus
rien c'est à dire que la planche à
billets ne pourra plus fonctionner et
les généraux en rend moins de cash pour
payer les soldes des militaires et les
soldes des policiers il faut employer
tous ses moyens peut-être pas très
glorieux mais pour arriver à faire que
le régime
la junte ce biais du coup d'état les
terroristes qui attaquent la population
n'est plus d'argent n'est plus de cash
ce qui est pas important c'est leur
compte bancaire comme j'ai dit tout à
l'heure c'est surtout qui n'est plus
d'argent pour payer l'armée et les
policiers
cela passera forcément par l'argent le
nerf de la guerre ont bien mené par
l'argent et tout à l'heure vous avez
cité le rôle des ethnies je crois qu'il
faut parier beaucoup sur les troupes des
ethnies à la frontière de la chine et de
la thaïlande il ya beaucoup d'ethnies
qui ont des forces armées bien entraînés
relative bien équipé et qui viennent de
se rallier massivement aux
protestataires et je crois qu'il faut
aider et financièrement et en leur
fournissant des armes
ces ethnies elles ont commencé à
attaquer des postes militaires et des
postes de police
il faut qu'elle continue et
effectivement on va vers une guerre
civile
à moins que des négociations puissent
venir mais les généraux sont
complètement obtus ils font fi des
déclarations internationales et des
différentes positions qui sont prises
contre eux ils massacrent la population
car dans aucun pays au monde on voit
l'armée tiré à balles réelles avec des
balles à grande vitesse
et avec des fusils à lunettes carrées
ici ils ciblent les têtes et les thorax
c'est à dire des cibles pour tuer et ils
tuent 35 enfants un tas de jeunes qui
elles sont révoltés contre la hiérarchie
militaire et ça c'est absolument
scandaleux vous savez le mouvement je
serai pardonnez-moi de l'armée tire dans
les jambes à faut d'habitude l'armée
tire dans les jambes dans tous les pays
civilisés quand ils ont attiré mais
jamais dans les têtes et dans les thorax
avec des fusils à lunettes
c'est à dire pour tuer dans les jambes
je suis chirurgien orthopédiste
on peut réparer et un tuba et quand les
militaires on voit des blessés et les
emmène non pas à l'hôpital mais les
emmène dans les prisons ou dans les
postes de police et malheureusement
lendemain les familles sont priés de
venir chercher les corps
c'est absolument abjecte vous savez en
plus le mouvement de désobéissance
civile a été initiée par les médecins et
les infirmières qui ont déserté les
hôpitaux publics se sont repliés sur les
hôpitaux civils où il soigne
gratuitement les blessés et les malades
mais les hôpitaux ont été occupées par
les militaires qui en ont fait leur camp
de base qui est sont des camps situés au
milieu des villes et c'est absolument
scandaleux je sais pas dans quel état on
retrouvera ensuite les hôpitaux et moi
mais à l'instant l'émissaire de l'onu on
vient d'apprendre puisque je vous le
rappelle
le conseil de sécurité réuni en urgence
à new york l'émissaire de l'onu appelle
à utiliser aussi tous les moyens pour
éviter un bain de sang alors bon c'est
vrai que voilà ces prosélytes comme
déclaration ça veut dire quoi à tous les
moyens est ce qu'on est capable
d'envoyer des casques bleus où des des
mercenaires armés et a bombardé certains
sites
un épi dont la capitale vous savez je
suis sûr que les routes les satellites
américains connaissent au mètre près les
habitations des généraux les véhicules
des généraux etc
mais c'est un acte de guerre je sais pas
si l'onu est prête à à permettre une
ingérence l'ingérence quand les droits
humains sont bafoués peut se concevoir
et c'est conçu dans un certain nombre de
pays
ça serait souhaitable car cette
population et une population pacifique
bouddhiste formidable qui se fait
massacrer et c'est surtout la jeunesse
qui ce qui est en première ligne et dans
les barricades
car cette jeunesse là connu depuis dix
ans l'internet les téléphones mobiles
facebook tout et on les voit la manu
avec des frondes ou des des catapultes
ou même des arcs j'ai vu se battre
contre les militaires ce qu'il faut bien
noter s'adonner mois à l'agente a lancé
son coup d'état ensuite aux élections de
novembre 2020 qui selon eux ont été
entachées de d'irrégularités est ce que
ces accusations sont totalement
infondées selon vous aubin selon - oui
j'ai infondées il y avait des comités de
surveillance même internationaux non ils
ont fait le coup d'état parce que il
voyait que le mld avec madame en dessous
qui avait gagné 80% des sièges qu'ils
allaient perdre leur majorité au
parlement et que de fait ils ont 25 %
des sièges qui sont dévolues à l'armée
mais qu' il savait parfaitement que une
des premières choses que ferait le
nouveau gouvernement
c'est abolir la constitution 2008 de
faire une nouvelle constitution
en retirant une partie des rois de
l'armée et les généraux et les sous les
eaux grand officier
voyez leur pactole fuir puisque il
allait perdre là la main mise sur les
entreprises et sur les revenus
car les sont immensément riche et leur
fortune mais bien souvent dans des
paradis fiscaux
bien caché pendant population et il y
aura sûrement un grand grand projet
d'aidé humanitaire car il va falloir
redonner de l'argent redonner de
l'alimentation et toute cette population
qui depuis deux mois a arrêté de
travailler il faut aider la birmanie
merci alain patel je rappelle que vous
êtes président de l'association médicale
france asiatiques
laurent gbagbo est charles blé goudé
définitivement hors de cause la chambre
d'appel de la cour pénale internationale
de la haye aux pays bas vient de
confirmer cet après-midi l'équipement de
l'ex président de la côte d'ivoire et de
son bras droit prononcée en première
instance en 2019
les deux hommes étaient poursuivis pour
crimes contre l'humanité la décision
pourrait ouvrir la voie à un retour
politique de l'ex chef d'état ivoirien à
abidjan le procureur a choisi de fonder
son appel sur des allégations d'erreur
juridique et procédural
plutôt que de faire figurer les erreurs
a légué comme des erreurs factuelles
soit le procureur n'apporte pas
d'arguments convaincants sur la manière
dont les airs a allégué dans l'es6
exemple ont affecté matériellement la
décision ces exemples incluent des
erreurs des incohérences concernant un
certain nombre de questions factuelles
qui ne sont pas toutes liées à des
incidents qui concernait deux accusés
dans cette affaire ou qui sont liées
directement à leurs conduites
individuelles l'équipe d'appel conclut
par le jugement majoritaire que la
chambre de première instance n'a pas
convaincu
et donc le deuxième tour d'appel des
procureurs est rejeté et retour en
images sur les dates clés d'une décennie
de péripéties
[Musique]
à
bah
[Musique]
pas
m
[Musique]
non
pour en parler nous sommes avec ludovic
emmanuelli président de l' ong
croissance peas bonsoir le lobby
qu'emmanuel ni merci d'être avec nous
alors tout d'abord l'acquittement de
laurent gbagbo pour vous c'est une
surprise
bonsoir alors j'ai pas tout entendu mais
j'ai entendu au début de votre question
est ce que c'est surtout une surprise
cet acquittement de laurent gbagbo oui
alors une surprise finalement il a été
il a été reconnu il avait que non
coupable donc par rapport aux événements
qui se sont produits la justice a
tranché là et a tranché gbagbo et son
acolyte blé goudé sont reconnus non
coupables peut écouter
laissons faire la justice internationale
c'est une très bonne chose pour eux il
doit savourer avec beaucoup de joie ce
dénouement
alors est ce qu'on peut parler
clairement aujourd'hui des chèques pour
la cpi alors vous avez d'un côté la cpi
et vous avez le côté la procureure ça
dépend de quel côté on se place
si c'est du côté de la cpi
on peut voir la chose comme une justice
finalement qui va arriver à son terme et
qui va déclarer un homme et enfin deux
hommes non coupable si parmi les les
gens qui ont regardé cette séquence
pendant ces dix dernières années surtout
pendant les deux dernières années on
leur demande aux pro gbagbo mais que
pensez vous de ces pays
certains vous diront que peut-être que
la cpi a voulu gagner du temps donc ça
dépend un peu de quel côté on se place
pour avoir une opinion
m'enfin moi ce que je retiens c'est que
le cpi a déclaré un homme innocent et
c'est une très bonne chose pour le pays
de la côte d'ivoire qui mérite du calme
et de la pénibilité clairement pour vous
la cour pénale internationale agit en
toute indépendance
normalement oui elle devrait agir en
bon je l'espère et on est là pour lui
faire confiance
sinon on ne s'en sort plus sûr fait plus
confiance aux grandes instances qui
dirige notre monde
quelque part on se met en porte-à-faux
par rapport aux décisions et on ne croit
plus rien non rien donc on va leur
donner crédit d'avoir reconnu peut-être
une erreur en gardant deux ans
complémentaires et en dégageant ces deux
personnes de toute culpabilité et donc
ils sont innocents c'est quelque chose
je vous dis qui est formidable on en
parlera peut-être pour la côte d'ivoire
après alors justement se vendent
réconciliation qui souffle sur la côte
d'ivoire est ce que ça peut avoir un
rapport avec cet acquittement ça a été
en tout cas peut-être influencé par ce
vent de réconciliation alors ce qui se
passe c'est que le président ouattara a
tout intérêt pour son pays à ce que son
pays redevienne la côte d'ivoire d'antan
et très moderne qui a une audience qui a
une luminosité dans le dans l'afrique de
l'ouest et qui rayonne dans le monde
entier et pour ce faire
s'il réussit la réconciliation alors là
il aura quasiment tout gagné
alors je dois vous dire que qu'il a
nommé un ministre qui s'appelle kkb qui
est ministre de la réconciliation qui
doit agir entre l'ex président gbagbo
l'ex-président bédié pour essayer de
faire en sorte que les trois puissent
retrouver et que la côte d'ivoire
redevienne cette nation extraordinaire
qui était publicité par le monde entier
pour ses talents qui se trouve au pays
et son développement
va-t-il y arriver il faut y croire alors
clairement est ce qu'on peut s'attendre
maintenant à voir revenir laurent gbagbo
sur le devant de la scène ivoirienne au
d'éthique ivoirienne laurent gbagbo
oui laurent gbagbo est d'abord ivoirien
ivoirien
donc son intérêt et puis ce peut-être le
fait de rencontrer ses amis le poussera
retourner dans son pays
donc en côte d'ivoire et je lui sois et
j'espère qu'il pourra y retrouver
confort amis et pourra y retrouver aussi
des gens avec qui peut-être reconstruire
puisque maintenant le temps est
peut-être de penser à une reconstruction
d'une autre côte d'ivoire qui sera à
l'image de celle qui est attendu par le
peuple c'est-à-dire paisible et qui soit
en développement et en croissance
exponentielle alors si laurent gbagbo et
son ministre blé goudé ont été acquittés
ça veut dire quoi que les crimes commis
en 2011 resteront impunis alors si si on
s'en tient à la loi ce qui a été fait
pour le moment il n'y a que des
supputations ou des discussions de
comptoir qui vont enfin comptoir et
c'est pas péjoratif qui vont donner les
attributions sur la culpabilité de telle
ou telle la justice internationale a
tranché peut-être dans une sagesse
africaine pour pouvoir permettre une
réconciliation constructive et efficace
laissons à cette institution son choix
et appuyons la merci du 2vic emmanueli
champlain que vous êtes président
llorente croissance fils merci de nous
avoir apporté votre expertise sur
l'afrique est justement en afrique de
l'ouest toujours au niger le
gouvernement confirme une tentative de
coup d'état pour je cite mettre en péril
la démocratie
arrestation de plusieurs militaires la
nuit dernière d'après une source
sécuritaire ce matin la situation et je
cite sous contrôle des tirs nourris à
l'armé lourde ont été entendus dans le
quartier du plateau à niamey la capitale
proximité de la résidence présidentielle
selon le témoignage de plusieurs
riverains des tirs survenus
veille de l'intronisation de main du
nouveau président élu mohamed bazoum son
rival l'ex président mahamane ousmane
conteste ces résultats et a appelé à des
marches pacifiques dans tout le pays et
non tentative de coup d'état a été
déjoué une enquête est ouverte
les investigations c'est possible pour
identifier et interpeller les auteurs et
leurs complices afin de les mettre à la
disposition de la justice est là mais
bleu même pour le commanditaire internes
et externes et dans le reste de
l'actualité nouveau drame on afghanistan
trois jeunes femmes ont été assassinées
hier dans le pays alors qu'elle
participait à une campagne de
vaccination des meurtres qu'ils
n'entrent l'incertitude sécuritaire dans
lequel se trouve le pays alors que les
pourparlers entre kaboul et les talibans
patine en fait le point avec théo combes
ce sont des scènes auxquelles les
afghans assistent depuis plusieurs
dizaines d'années
trois nouvelles victimes de l'insécurité
chronique qui règne dans le pays sont
enterrés devant leurs familles
trois jeunes femmes afghanes qui
participaient à une simple opération de
vaccination contre la polio deux de nos
soeurs vaccine attriste antipolio sont
venus ici pour vacciner les enfants
elle attendait les enfants devant cette
maison à ce moment là trois hommes armés
portant des voiles se sont avancés dans
la rue ils ont attaqué les vaccine
attriste et les ont tués
elle était allongée là bas ma fille
travaillait comme vaccine attriste pour
l'unicef et elle travaillait aussi à
l'hôpital de djalal abad
aujourd'hui j'ai reçu un appel disant
votre fille a été abattu quand je suis
arrivé sur le site de l' attaque
j'ai vu deux corps l'un était ma fille
bassir à et un autre ce n'est pas la
première fois que des campagnes de
vaccination sont entravés par des
violences dans le pays
les talibans qui contrôlent de larges
pans du territoire afghan continuent
d'interdire aux autorités de mener ses
campagnes une situation sécuritaire
dégradée liés à la lenteur et la
confusion qui entoure les pourparlers
actuellement en cours entre les talibans
et le gouvernement de kaboul
les meurtres déplacement et souffrances
du peuple afghans doivent cesser
maintenant les négociations continuent
aujourd'hui mais piétine en raison d'un
manque de résultats réels mais
clairement il faut faire plus pour
démontrer aux afghans que les
négociations progressent dans l'intérêt
réel du peuple afghan
depuis septembre dernier les deux
parties négocient à doha au qatar des
pourparlers qui n'ont pas encore abouti
alors que le retrait des troupes
américaines est initialement prévu pour
le mois de mai prochain sans accord pour
un gouvernement de transition
la situation pourrait rapidement devenir
explosive en afghanistan selon l'onu
plus de 80 personnes ont été assassinées
rien que depuis le début de l'année dans
le pays c'est la fin de cette émission
prochain point complet sur l'actualité
dans quelques minutes à 22h
[Musique]
il ya à peu près un enfant sur deux en
france qui est soit victime soit hauteur
de cyber violence sur internet un
contenu haineux de quelqu'un qui dit à
une fillette de 8 ans va de suicide et
ça ça doit être retirée immédiatement il
n'ya aucun débat à avoir sur son retrait
là parce que ça ça fait des suicides la
loi le condamne déjà c'est déjà interdit
de faire ça bien sûr mais c'est juste
que les gaffes à ne l'appliquent pas la
justice est lente et c'est très
problématique qui doit prendre ce rôle
de régulateur la loi peut aider
l'éducation peut aider selon les
différentes catégories d'attaquants et
d'attaquer une erreur de la loi via ça a
été de tout mettre dans le même panier
sous le sous le nom est en ligne quel
rôle pour les réseaux sociaux on a vu
les big for bouclé gaza s'organiser pour
annuler quelqu'un sur internet ce
quelqu'un c'était donald trump quand il
s'agit d'un bannissement si général pour
moi ce n'est pas aux gaffes à et aux
réseaux sociaux à dole à des entreprises
privées de prendre cette décision mais
ça doit être à la justice de prendre
cette décision
[Musique]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
nous sommes une équipe
[Musique]
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même un
certain lien de confiance est rompu
entre le politique et les experts et
même les citoyens on est une société qui
est totalement